house finance committee i find that due
to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the covet
19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 as
extended
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming
several things we are a providing public
access to the meeting by telephone and
with additional access possibilities
by video or other electronic means
we are using the zoom video webinar for
this remote meeting all members of the
committee and the staff of the state
agencies with agenda items
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously
watch and or listen to the meeting on
zoom or phone
following the directions and links
provided in the house
calendar starting at house calendar 8
going through the current version 12.
b that this group is providing
public notice of necessary information
for accessing the meeting we previously
gave notice to the public of the
necessary information for accessing the
meeting
telephonically instructions have been
provided in the house calendar
see providing a mechanism for the public
to alert
the public body let us know in other
words
during the meeting if there are problems
with access if anyone has a problem
please email the following email address
l b a underscore fiscal f
i s c a l at leg
l e g dot state dot new hampshire dot u
s
uh in the event that the public is
unable to access the meeting we'll go
ahead and adjourn and reschedule
i don't anticipate any votes today but
any votes taken
shall be done by a roll call
so um so we're going to start here with
the roll call
in a minute i i want to let you know
that representative rogers
is going to have to step away around 10
o'clock for
maybe as much as an hour i i would like
to do a recess
from around 10 minutes after 11
00 to noon think about that and if
anyone has a problem with that you know
let me know
before we get to the recess point okay
so let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
and that's required under our right to
know law
so mr clerk could you take the
attendance please
representative earth present alone in my
home office
representative weiler i'm alone in this
room in kingston there are others in the
house
representative bean i'm in guilford in
my home
my wife is in and out representative
walner
i'm at home in my home in concord and my
husband is
um in in the house
representative i'm alone in my dining
room at my house in hanover
rogers um i am alone um
in my apartment in concord with my dog
representative edwards alone in my home
office in
auburn my wife may walk in to refill my
coffee
all members present
thank you so much so um
so the big news uh from last meeting
is that mr ripple was able to get the
recordings of our previous
meetings up uh online they're at the uh
division three web page if uh if for any
reason you have
a need to go take a look at something
that was actually said during one of our
prior meetings
so that's new news uh with that i think
mr ripple we're ready for um
mrs santaniello yes
so karen and chris santaniello
and i think rebecca lorton will be
joining
morning miss rounds good morning
thank you for having mr williams call me
and educate me yesterday about the
rsa um i now know
he has great authority to reconstitute
his agency however he ceased fed or she
sees that so thank you you're very
welcome
john is uh the knowledge bank of the
department when it comes to statutes so
happy that he could help you out
so i'm going to turn things over to
chris and you're also uh
meeting a new finance director today
rebecca lorden not new to the department
just
new to you face wise she covers
dehs as well as dcyf so you will see her
today and again
next week
i want to be where she is she's on a
beach
actually i want to be where you are for
someone to refill my coffee but that's
okay
so i was really jealous
my name is chris santaniello and can you
hear me okay i've been having
sound difficulty so i'm gonna try to
wear my headset
all day today um my name is chris
santaniello i
um so good morning chair edwards and
committee members of division three
finance i
am very happy to be here this morning
um and i am here in my office in concord
by myself
um so what i thought we would do today
the division of economic and housing
stability
is a relatively large division within
the department
and so what i thought i would do is
um just give you a high level overview
of what
dehs is and then we're going to go
through later
this morning and into the afternoon each
of the bureaus
and that is where actually all of the
finances are are
within the bureaus they're not within
our division but i thought it was
important if it's okay with you all
um to start with just a division
overview
are you able to see my hand yes okay so
if there are questions throughout
your presentation i'll just raise my
hand i want you to go ahead and complete
your thought
uh it doesn't need to be a hard
interrupt i just yep
okay that sounds good so can everybody
hear me okay
yes and i would like to give you a heads
up that i
i want to spend additional time more
than you probably planned
around the slides leading up to and
including
the social determinants of health okay
that sounds good to me okay
so i'm just going to get started um with
the
mission of the division for economic and
housing stability it's to advance
the economic the health economic and
social well-being
of individuals families and communities
and our vision is that individuals and
families
sounds like you're reading off of a
slide can we present her slide myself oh
i'm so sorry should i be doing
no if it's fine if if if if you have a
slide deck we should be following
we just want to have the slide deck up
so we know what's
what's up you know what i'd kevin do you
have them or do you want me
i'll i'll do it i think you should be
able to share your screen if you have
them
yep i just have to um i'm sorry i was
this is just a little new doing it this
way
um but i will pull them up right now
it really kind of works out great
because everyone knows exactly where
you're at
follow along it's really good it's fine
okay so now i'm gonna do screen share
and then i don't have to keep on saying
um why can't i
wait a second sorry okay
why is it not showing up well one second
technical difficulty here let me just do
it one more time
all right here we go dave i think dave's
gonna try to jump over i'm all set i got
it
thank you it helps to have dave in the
office next to me
um so um
i'm just going to go to the next slide
all right all right so our mission um
which is not actually in statute or
rule um this is something that the um
division heads and i came up with um
about a year ago it's to advance the
health economic
and social well-being of individuals
families and communities
and and when we get to that point we
think
that our vision will be that individuals
and families are strong
resilient and thriving in their
communities
and the next slide shows you the
programs
and bureaus that we're going to talk
about within the division of economic
and housing stability
so that includes the bureaus of family
assistance
employment support somebody probably
should go on mute
i think maybe representative waller you
got some background noise
new heights the bureau of child support
services
the bureau of housing supports we also
have
comprehensive family support and family
resource centers
the bureau of child development and head
start collaboration
and while the preschool development
grant is not a
department program it is something that
we are working on collaboratively
with the department of education
and through the university of new
hampshire so i just wanted to point that
out here
okay now all of those eight boxes
are divisions or bureaus is that correct
the preschool development grant is not
is a
program that we work in collaboration
new heights is our i.t infrastructure
for this division and other parts of the
department
and then comprehensive family supports
is a
program so that's not a division and i'm
going to talk about
a couple of those programs here in this
overview
all eight of those boxes uh receive
state funds or or some of them federal
funds only
so the preschool development grant is
federal um and that is the money is not
even with our
department it's with the university of
new hampshire
um and i believe
everything else which we will get to in
later slides has a combination of
federal and um
state general funds
okay um so the
um our division our focus is we serve
individuals and families from
birth on through the life span our aim
is to really
provide a whole person whole family
approach
we emphasize the importance of social
determinants of health
and the impact it has on an individual
and family
one of our goals is to really
focus on reducing programmatic and
system barriers
we we have a tendency to have
people fit programs not have the other
way around and programs fit people
and so that's some of the work we're
trying to get to
um we're really focused on strengthening
programs
organization and have be solution
focused
and shared um leadership and integration
and working together
so i have a question there okay the the
third bullet
about social determinants of health and
its impact
is that a statutory thing or is that
something the commissioner and you came
up with
that is something that we came up here
without the department
okay okay so
that um ties in really well into the
social determinants of health
and these are really kind of these are
known as the conditions in which people
yep hold on a second i
okay thank you oh
dave's helping me for some coffee now
and you're good exactly
i know i wish i could um so
um thanks dave are the conditions in
which people
are born grow live work and age and if
you look
at the social determinants of health
there are lots of things
maybe um that we wouldn't necessarily
think of when we think of the department
of health and human services yet
we touch all of these social
determinants of health in some way
within this division
and so i think we really try to look at
these when we
work do some of our work that if you
think about
education children are ready to learn
well that impacts our bureau of child
development and head start collaboration
employment and income stability that
crosses our bureau of child
support bureau of family assistance
bureau of employment supports
health and well-being that's access to
health care
housing stability we hear about that all
the time if a family
um isn't stable in their housing and
they're having
to move multiple um times that's going
to
impact a family and so all and food and
nutrition so all of these pieces
um touch in some way on um
within our division of economic and
housing stability
so i have about eight questions on this
slide
i hope i have any eight answers oh you
do
i hope so these are these are all
one-on-one questions for you
okay so graphically this
suggests and it probably doesn't mean to
but it implies that all of these
determinants
are co-equal that they uh have an equal
balance and equal
importance and therefore an equal
prioritization
within the department is
that that's probably the wrong graphical
takeaway are there
are there priorities in here for what
you uh
your bureau is looking at so within
here um there's certain pieces that
this division does have an impact on
directly so that would be housing
stability
um and we're going to hear a lot more
about that with our bureau of housing
supports
i think employment and income stability
um and i'm going to talk a little bit in
a little later about
some of our efforts for upward economic
mobility so i think
housing and employment as well as access
to health care
food and nutrition education it's hard
to say
okay what are the pieces that are most
important because it all makes up a
person and a family and a community
but the pieces that we have the most
influence on i would say um
are food and nutrition kind of over to
housing stability if you're going
counter clockwise and then early
education
okay and then i don't actually see
healthcare delivery on here but i think
you
suggested that it was under the health
and well-being that the healthcare
delivery system is somewhere in health
and well-being
yep i think that's their desired level
of physical
mental and emotional health and this
division
doesn't um doesn't have responsibilities
for the actual
health care service system we
um facilitate access to that so you'll
hear more
from henry lippman later when he talks
about
the division of medicaid services but we
partner
very closely with medicaid because
people access medicaid
through on the bureau of family
and then assistance see under well-being
uh emotional health so
that makes me wonder is that something
we're going to put into a database
somewhere so we can do population
management on emotional health
so i'm going to defer that to
when katya fox talks later
because she has the bureau of behavioral
health again these are
all aspects of someone's health and
well-being and we
focus on access to those programs
does that help well it does and i'll
just tell you
you know maybe you can tell from my
questions but i'm i'm really concerned
about the future of dhhs
managing or getting involved
in the totality of the social
determinants of health
this is uh this is a potential area of
massive scope creep um
to what the mission of dhhs was
initially
thought to be um i
i very much am a big supporter of
dhhs having a direct
hands-on relationship to
new hampshire's healthcare provider
network
and as um as a human
living in new hampshire i'm concerned
about these things
that are on this slide but i'm just
really concerned
about um a state entity thinking it's
their responsibility to manage
this on behalf of the population
and i think that could just be way too
interventionist
yeah and so um so this is
so this is i'm not i'm not going to be
hostile
but i am going to ask you a lot of
questions about
how much money are you spending in these
areas to do
more the distinction between monitoring
status
and intervening to ensure the economic
stability of families
i think that's a gray area that we
really need to look at
so just to clarify
we don't have responsibility for all
of these areas we need to understand the
social determinants of health and where
we intersect with those
and so when we're working with an
individual and
family it's important for us to
understand
do they have food and nutrition and can
we assist with access to that
you know are there employment
opportunities and
income stability we can assist with but
we don't
take responsibility for all of these
pieces these are
all of the things that make individuals
families and communities healthy
um and thrive and so we have certain
pieces of those but not
clearly all of them all right well thank
you
it's the beginning of a good long
conversation so so continue
okay dave is um doing something with my
computer
i don't know what he's gonna
i don't know what it is it's not coffee
though okay
are we okay was there too much showing
okay sorry about that so okay
good thing i didn't do this at home okay
so now i can't move to the next slide
okay so a couple of the programs i
wanted to touch on that
are not going to be highlighted so much
in the other
areas is family support we have
community service block grant and
whole families approach to jobs so
the first piece is our family support
and this is um we have comprehensive
family support
which is a um home visiting program that
is focused on strengthening parents
in an effort to reduce child
maltreatment and increase
child and family well-being this program
is
voluntary it serves individuals and
families from birth on through the life
span
and really what the focus is is trying
to assist
families when they say i need a little
bit of help with
parenting um in a preventative way so
that they don't need
more intrusive services later on through
dcyf
we also provide access to
family resource centers across the state
of new hampshire
and those are primary prevention
services and many communities have them
um and they offer such services as
parenting education
workshops a place for families to go
when they're not sure where to turn and
access to services
and then finally we work very closely
with the new hampshire children's trust
fund
and they provide infrastructure support
quality designation and
support to the family resource centers
to be able to do their jobs
and a new program over the last i want
to say a couple of years
has been in the area of kinship
navigation
as some of you may be aware we have a
large
number of family members who are
either raising grandchildren
other family members and lots of times
they need
some additional support and kinship
navigation is a way
to give those families access to
services and supports
so that the children can remain with the
family and not need to be in foster care
through the division
for children youth and families
we also have the community services
block grant
and that those funds go directly to the
five community action agencies across
the
state of new hampshire and this is
federal dollars but it's really
um has an a focus to
reduce poverty um and so
the community action agencies are
granted
the majority of those dollars for
direct service for infrastructure as
well as an
opportunity to develop innovative
programs across
the entire family and finally
we um have the whole family's approach
to jobs parents working
on children thriving and representative
walner
actually has been very involved in our
efforts across the state with this and
this is
an effort actually that um governor
sununu
um was is behind and really assisting
families to get out of poverty through
work at the same time supporting
business
because prior to the pandemic we know
that new hampshire's unemployment was
really low
but yet and there were families who are
receiving
public benefits um and some of those
families
weren't able to work because of this
um real phenomenon called the cliff
effect
and what that is it's that's when a
family
an individual either starts to work
um is coming off of public assistance
but yet the benefits the loss of benefit
the
increase in income does not match the
loss of benefits and families
actually end up being worse off
by working or taking a promotion
than not working and as a state
one of the things is we need as many
workers as we can as we move into the
future
and also we know that a family that
has its own economic resources
is working in the long run is going to
be better for the individual the family
and the community as a whole
and so we've been partnering with new
hampshire employment security
to conduct an economic analysis to say
okay are there certain policy changes we
need to make
and how we administer benefits that
enable
people to work so that's some of the
work that we're
focusing on yep so
new hampshire has bureaus of uh
economic assistance and bia and
and there are other entities within
state government that worry about the
health of the economy
yeah so when i look at a dhhs slide
that says your mission includes creating
economic mobility pathways
that reads to me like something that is
not
in the dhhs mission so
where so what what is in our mission
is um access to
let's say for example child care
scholarship which we're going to talk
about
after this presentation so the child
care scholarship or temporary assistance
to needy families
as a department we set
the policy for those programs
and if the child care scholarship
the loss of that benefit makes it so
people
don't want to work and then that impacts
other state departments that's what we
need to understand
so we can say maybe we need to change
the access to child care scholarship
so that it encourages more people to
work
and have people come off of unemployment
so it's not our responsibility
to do the employment pieces
and the business development but what
are the policies that
inhibit some of people coming to work
that is within our control that sounds
reasonable
okay representative walner i have a
question for you since your name was
mentioned
um so so i i've been concerned about
this cliff effect
where where people on who are on
public assistance who go into the
private employment
they lose so much in benefits it's not
worth the money that they make in the
in the job market and so i'm curious
what you know about previous efforts
to create sort of an incremental
stepwise
approach so that there's a staircase
there instead of a cliff
well i the the program that i could
speak the bet
most about is child care and in child
care there are
there are steps so a parent comes in
they are eligible for the program for
the scholarship
um they come in a fee the parent fee
is um set according to their income so
let's say this is
someone just coming off public
assistance their income's very low
um they would have a low fee but as they
get a raise at work
then they pay more of their part and the
scholarship is less
and the parent pays more and there are
several steps
to work towards gradually having the
person
take full responsibility for uh paying
for
child care and no longer needing the
scholarship
so i think that's you know that's sort
of an example
there are there's work to be done in
that area but that is an example of how
they have
sort of started to work on the cliff
effect and that
is why would you agree with that yes and
actually um i just was sending out the
draft
the final report um to the um committee
members and
one of the things they're recommending
is that
yes as representative walner mentioned
there are
steps throughout child care scholarship
but then when you get to the end it's a
really big drop um and i'm sure
representative walner um can attest to
that it is a big drop
and that's where families are really
struggling with do i
stay working do i take the promotion and
so that's one of the areas
where we really need to invest some of
our um
time and energy to say do we have more
steps
that are more gradual um than we offer
now
so if you need help with that i'd be
happy to help you with that because i
i it's a great concept i don't want to
create
perverse incentives for people to stay
on public assistance
i think the emotional well-being of an
individual increases when they have a
job and they feel
productive so that is great and actually
if you're
interested i can actually send you the
economic analysis
once we have that for you to review
we with the partnership with new
hampshire employment security we looked
at
the state 40 different communities in
town so we really try to get a diverse
representation
in different parts of the state so we're
really hoping it's going to help us
move some of this forward thank you
before you get going again there's been
a lot of discussion here are there any
questions from the committee members in
here
i'm not seeing any um you can get going
before i interrupt you again okay that's
fine
whoops okay
okay um so i just wanted to talk and i
believe
that um dave weeders
who is on the line right now
did mention a little bit about the new
heights system
and the new height system is
programmatically housed within the
division of economic and housing
stability and so we have
um an integrated eligibility
system which assists
with access to services for
medicaid child care snap
tanf access to long-term care
so it's a very robust
system that drives eligibility
for services within the department
through new heights we also have
new hampshire easy which gives
individuals the access to
apply for benefits online and also
upload documents and do some different
things
via an online portal any questions on
this right now
no i'm i'm kind of up on new heights
okay all right great
um good to know um and so
one of the complications of new heights
um
because it's integrated which for the
consumer um is
is excellent there's lots of other
states that do not have integrated
eligibility systems
but what that means is that we have to
work with lots of different
federal authorities um when we are
working on any new heights changes and
so it's not just
medicaid it's also food and nutrition
services
and the administration for children and
families so
anytime we think about having to make
changes um with heights it
we can't if it's we can't just work with
one of our federal partners it's working
with all three of them
um which sometimes can make um
life a little more complicated i have a
couple questions here
okay and it may be mr waters needs to
answer
part of it but um so this slide implies
that all of these compliance
requirements
have been fully implemented and are now
fully supported
is that is that what this slide is
supposed to say
or are there some of these that are
still uh
tbd so i'm
my um we are in compliance with
all of these um areas um i do have lori
snow
who's the administrator and dave weeders
on
um this zoom if you would like more
specific
questions well that's a good one okay
my next question and you don't know the
answer i'm sure is that we talked to
uh meredith tell us yesterday the day
before i've
it's all blurring together but um she
had some
uh eligibility uh system
requirements that would said that she
said would uh
simplify a tremendous amount of her
manpower
um and i'm just curious
if you know where she is on the list of
of implementations so i um
my understanding is what um
what meredith will do is she will
look at um pieces of
the new heights data one of the things
that she's looking at
is video interviewing so that they
um don't have to go out into people's
homes and that's something that would be
built through heights but the other
piece is when
meredith's group looks at some of their
data integration some of that comes from
mmis
if they're looking at claims and things
like that
i just i'm a little foggy i'd have to
look at my notes i thought she had
another
a set of requirements for eligibility
management that
that were not yet implemented so i can
get back to you and find out exactly
what those may be is that okay
oh sure and that's over the next
few weeks don't hurry on that one okay
yep i will do that so
um eligibility requirements all right
i will um follow up on that definitely
anything else nope okay thank you
great um so this is
just a overview of the um
different bureaus within our division
you'll see bureau of family assistance
and employment on staff we have about
455 staff
and it's about 120 million dollars
bureau of child support is here the gray
circle that's 127 staff
our bureau of housing supports has five
and child development and head start
collaboration have
ten um the bureau of housing supports
which we're gonna hear about in two
bureaus from now
um contracts out all services so that's
why
they have the limited number of staff so
i'm i'm just
doing the math of the staff in my head
here
i'm thinking that new hampshire has 1.3
million
plus or minus and is there is there a
an external benchmark for how many
people
ought to be working these programs uh
given
population size so
by each program there
are certain benchmarks for the bureau
of child support and the same for family
assistance and employment supports and
we'll get into a little bit of that
when we um talk when we get into those
bureaus because for the bureau of family
assistance
we have um deadlines for timeliness
and um you know application um
error you know efficiencies and the same
with bureau of child support we have
very specific time limitations and so
there are some benchmarks which i can
get those for you i don't have those
with me today
okay all right
i'm just writing myself notes there's a
question there
by representative wallner okay yes thank
you uh just while we're at this slide
um i'm looking at the staffing could you
um tell us how much a vacancy rate you
have at this point
um off the top of my head
i do not know that rebecca do you know
off the top of your head
no i don't have that information on me
at this time i can get that for you
um we have um the one
thing um i know in the bureau of housing
support we have one vacant position
i know in child development head start
collaboration we have two
um and in the bureau of child support
family assistance and employment
supports when we did have the hiring
freeze
the those workers were considered direct
care workers so for eligibility and
child support officers so they were not
part of the hiring freeze um but i can
get the actual vacancies for you by
bureau
i was particularly wondering about the
uh bureau of family assistance
it's got 455 staff i wondered what
what the number was there yeah
i can get that for you um probably by
the time we hit that um
presentation okay great thank you yeah
deb sorely if you're listening um
representative nordgren has a question
okay i can't see that
okay hi good morning thank you good
morning
yeah could you mention the hiring freeze
could you please talk a little bit about
that
the time frame how it affected your
department
where it is now sure
um so when we had the hiring freeze
and i honestly i don't remember actually
when it started
um to be quite honest with you um
we actually um in our
bureau of child support
family assistance and employment
supports
the frontline workers so for
family assistance that is the family
service specialist the person that
um an individual will meet with to get
access to benefits in the bureau of
employment supports that's an employment
counselor
and in child support it's the child
support officer
those positions were not part of the
hiring freeze
so we were free um to go ahead and hire
those positions because
they were considered direct care which
was extremely helpful
unfortunately some of these jobs are
entry-level
jobs so you do have a higher turnover
but in the area of but in the in
family assistance we have a policy unit
that works
on policy to support some of our
programs those weren't considered
direct care so those positions were
frozen and so for a while
um and also our training unit we were
moving staff around trying to make sure
we were
you know meeting all of our expectations
so all of those
have been lifted and we are actively
recruiting on those positions
thank you very much you're welcome are
there any other questions
i i have a question under the bureau of
family assistance
bureau of employment um
what do you what do you feel is about
the right number of job descriptions you
have throughout that 455
it's that you probably have 10 different
job descriptions in there or
or or what um
probably fss
one two three probably within
bfa i would say
there is probably around
10 or so um
and then employment supports there's
probably about
five or so one of the things the staff
have been working on the bureau chiefs
is when you have um certain
administrator positions they're a little
more generic
to the role of administering a program
and not so
program specific so that we can ebb and
flow so i
i can get you the exact number but i
would say probably about 10 to 15.
now what i'd really like here is um
an actual job description from for a
person
whose job it is is to engage
families engage clients a client facing
job description
okay great i will get that to you after
today is that helpful
great thanks okay
any other questions on this slide
okay so some of our key accomplishments
um is that we've brought together
multiple
program areas to form a division
with a focus on family strengthening and
upward economic mobility
i think one of this because this
division was formed
um in 2018 and so i think one of our
biggest
strengths has been we've been really
agile and nimble to meet the needs
during the pandemic
we have led many collaborative efforts
across
new hampshire the department and new
england
um with a real focus on being responsive
to the needs presented and
all of the different bureaus will talk
about that a little bit when we do
specific bureau presentations um
we've actually been yep
so as i as i read that i'm i'm i'm
my eye is catches family strengthening
and so that and since it's an
accomplishment it suggests
it's measurable and if it's measurable
that means somebody has developed a
baseline definition for what constitutes
a strong
family because if you don't have
criteria for what you think a strong
family is
it would be very hard to measure whether
or not you're making progress
so so i'm just i'm curious yeah i think
it's developed a definition on
what we consider the state view of a
strong family to be
so um i think there's a couple of
different measures
one of the measures we use is with our
comprehensive family support um
program which i mentioned earlier and
that
um is a preventative program
um and so one of the things we look at
is if a family we do this class of
data okay and so when we
have families who leave the program
every year
we follow them for about three years
and we see did they end up in dcyf
needing dcyf services for a period of
time
and um we track them for about three
years and so
when i look at the last three years so
for
people who left this program in 2018
89 of them continue to avoid
um dcyf services and so that's the major
measurement is whether or not they're
using dcyf services
that's one of the measurements another
measurement we look at
is how many people were we able through
new hampshire employment program to
actually get
jobs um because that's going to help a
family to
care for its own family during the
pandemic
one of the measures the um bureau of
employment supports looked at was the
number of people that they assisted
to obtain high school diplomas and so
that's a benchmark we look at so we try
to look across
all of our programs to see how many
families are we giving access to
are we assisting with child support
because that's helping to keep a family
strong
access to quality early childhood so we
look at a couple of different measures
across
all of our programs so so i'm just
trying to understand
uh the lines of delineation of
responsibility so
so moving people into employment i think
would be an accomplishment
of the division of of employment
services
and i would think the number of people
graduating would be an accomplishment of
the department of education
so so when i see a slide that says dehs
key accomplishments i i'm just curious
how um the actions and successes or
failures of these other departments
how how how they're viewed as
moving your mission forward yep so i
think it's and that's why
it's really important that we
collaborate with these other
departments and divisions because
while yes somebody completing high
school
is the response you know falls under
department of education
what we do is we assist with some of the
barriers that may be in the way of
somebody completing
on their education so through our tanf
program
we have barrier reduction services
through our
employment security our bureau of
employment support so that will help
with some of the cost accessing child
care an employment counselor to help
them
get through and maneuver so we partner
with those programs and provide the
supports that somebody needs to be
successful
okay we have been actively involved with
um the council on thriving children and
the council for housing stability and
we're really hoping
um that some of this work will help
the state um and the department look at
alternate at ways for people to maintain
their housing
um and again we are moving forward with
the economic analysis of the cliff
effect and that has been an
accomplishment because
we were working on it when the pandemic
hit
um and then um we you know
continued to have it evolve and grow um
through the um
and look from data that we collected
during the pandemic to help inform us
thank you yeah some of our
um challenges
are that there are siloed funding
streams
and i think that's something that
we're trying to really figure out
is because that creates silos of program
delivery right
if if you're working in a program and
you see
that you only the funding
you know is for x but yet the family
really needs why
how do we help support that and so
that's really a challenge
the other piece that goes with that is
you typically end up with departmental
uh information system silos as well
right i don't want to put words in your
mouth but i think that's coupled with
that right yeah interoperability of our
data systems
and so that's something that is a
challenge and then
you know workforce limitations right we
have um
there's you know a limited workforce and
so
um that also becomes difficult um
if we have you know um turnover um
and then also with our community
partners if they're having difficulty
um with hiring that also becomes a
challenge for us
um and then the um whoops
my slide the lack of interoperable data
systems is probably an artifact of the
fact that the programs
started siloed to begin with right yeah
and and i think some of that is some of
the federal regulations and really
understanding what they are and working
with our federal partners
for us to figure out the best ways
from a family perspective because i
think there's nothing worse
than providing your information and
telling your story
multiple times and so how do we how do
we help families get around that to make
sure that
you know um every door is the right door
and while
i may not have all of the programs they
need how do i get them
to those programs in the swiftest amount
of time
so i think um
one of the questions we were asked is a
five percent
increase or decrease and so if we had an
increase we would really enable
new heights which is rit system
to enhance support for critical services
we're really
working on how do we have
people get what they need through
technology and so
there's lots of things that we can
enhance
through our new heights in new hampshire
easy system as well as
support the field with technology
enhancements
so that would be critical for our
division
and then really continuing the work
with new hampshire children's trust
they're our facilitating
organization to really assist with
family resource centers which are across
the state of new hampshire
provide families with access
to services when they need them and
whether it's a parenting class whether
it's
a play group
whether it's going to somebody saying
i'm having these struggles
how can you help me get some services
for myself or a family member
so that families can remain
strong in their communities if we
have a decrease then really new heights
will not be able to meet some of our
technology needs
and then also some of our work
to strengthen families will have to be
decreased and then
it doesn't mean the needs go away right
it means that the needs will then show
up through dcyf
and so are there ways we can continue to
provide
preventative supports when families need
them at the right place
at the right location so they can get
access to the services
they need so thank you very much for
this slide
it i i realize it's a new slide um
so what would make this even more useful
to the committee i think
is if you could take these and make them
more
uh specific in the sense that they they
might become
measurable okay
it's hard to say you know what the
impact of the
top yeah
sure can and i can get that to you after
that's that's kind of a in a two-week
time frame kind of thing
yep that's fine think about it and give
us something
hard to where we say okay what are we
gonna get for our money
okay that sounds great thank you very
much
um and then the final piece is um and
we're gonna talk about these
um at in each bureau but i just wanted
to give you a high
level um of our division's prioritized
needs
and again these will be talked about in
each of the bureaus because that's where
the funding is
but these were our prioritized needs
and so you'll see they
vary um with child care it's our protect
and prevent
our quality system and then housing has
a couple of very specific
um prioritized needs um and then we have
child
support and our family support
but again we'll talk about these um in
each of the bureau slides
so just relating this to the previous
slide it looks like some of these might
be
in the increment side yes what would be
measurable
now the zero dollars that means you
asked for it and the
governor's budget process zeroed it out
yeah these were our prioritized needs so
yes we did not receive any of these
dollars
did you get some of your prioritized
needs from the governor or
none of them rebecca i don't think we
got any of them did we
we did not get any representative
nordgren has a question sure
i can't hear her oh okay
representation could you want to
i'm sorry um so in the columns up at the
top
house bill was uh
with the fiscal year 22 house bill
1 with the fiscal year 22. so
way on the right side should that be
saying
a fiscal year 23
yeah yes thank you yes
okay thanks yeah
goodbye we all you know how many times
we reviewed this and i found a type uh
i neglected something on the next slide
deck i'm like oh but i already did the
pdf
so i was like uh you look at things so
many times so
so okay this is uh this is useful uh did
you
um what what is this child support out
of state mileage how much
do we need to go out of state what is
this like
one trip a year is that ten trips a year
no it's really uh
you know one or two trips a year um and
in this past year
obviously with covid we haven't used
that um
and so that would just be something for
next year and the in-state mileage is
really going to court and
um helping you know do their work
so if they're out of state how are they
still our responsibility
no no it would be like if somebody had
to go to a conference
oh child support out of state mileage is
not to support a child it's just
the training yes
sorry about that no problem
and then the next slide is just some of
the areas in family support and bfa
um and we'll talk about all of those um
when we get to the actual um
what is an empath membership
yep it is a professional association
that assists our employment support
counselors
um with assisting people to
um who are on our tanf um temporary
assistance to needy families
come off of tanf through employment
one membership or is that like a group
it's a whole group membership
um for like you know a whole
year and it supports all the staff on
with you know some conferences some
technical assistance
so
was there a question i'm no i'm saying
you can continue
okay um and and then um
this is just our staffing um and so
i just wanted people um this is just a
summary of the staffing in our budgets
so this is it for the overview slide
so we were then going to move to
the bureau of child development and
um head start collaboration if that's
okay with everybody
let's let's let's just do a sanity check
on that
is this a mr ripple is this a good time
are there associated budgets that we
should dive into
from here or or do we need to see the
other slide deck before
any of the
this i think was the bigger picture
presentation i don't think there's a
budget associated with that one i think
we would move on is that right karen
okay yeah all right go on to the next
one
so so as a time check i would like to
take a recess
in about 40 minutes 4-0
so um has anyone come up with a reason
we shouldn't
recess then let me know
all right go ahead
you're good chris you ready okay so we
don't
we don't we we can continue right yes
okay so can you see my slide
yes okay all right i'm just going to
pull
another piece of paper yeah can you um
share just the presentation and not the
entire screen
um sure i don't know
i'm not what happens if you hit
presentation mode on your powerpoint
well um why is it nothing's happening
actually
can you all right dave
it doesn't bother me one second
move it here
but then i need to move them over here
okay one second
okay
okay is that
not sharing okay yep i'm working on it
right here okay
is that can you see it all now yes thank
you chris
all right sorry oh my goodness okay
we'll get there
okay so this is our um bureau of child
development
and head start collaboration
and if my cursor is not on the right
screen
so the mission statement
of the bureau of child development and
head start collaboration
is to partner with child care licensing
the head start community
department of education and others to
ensure that all children enrolled in
early childhood out of school programs
experience continuity in a high quality
setting
this statute is not um
and this is not in statute it is our own
um mission statement but we do include
it in our state plan that we
um apply that we have to um comply with
so the overview
is that we administer the state general
funds for child
care we provide
funds to eligible families for children
up to the age of 13 years
we work to recruit enroll
train and support child care providers
we work very closely with the um
child care licensing unit which i
believe melissa saintsir
may have talked about on thursday
we also administer um
our child care development funds quality
initiatives
we ensure we try to ensure that we
partner
with other quality initiatives across
the state
we offer consumer education and
resources we provide access and
referrals for families
and we also work with school readiness
to ensure that children and child care
when they leave child care are actually
ready
to move forward with education
so our next slide these are the number
of
children who receive child care
scholarship and you'll see that these
numbers
have been decreasing um over the last
couple of years
and we are really trying to spend some
time
trying to determine um
why is the numbers decreasing some of
those numbers have to do
with the fact that people
are we have very low unemployment and so
people are working and they may be
making a little bit more money than our
scholarship
allows for or um one of the other things
that we talked about a little bit
earlier is the cliff effect
because this is for people that are
working and if
if if the scholarship doesn't assist
enough
um with the cost of child care
then families aren't going to work and
you know and even if a family receives
new hampshire child care scholarship
um they are still going to have some out
of pocket expenses and so
that's something that we're really
hoping to look at
um as we go through um all of our cliff
analysis child care is probably one of
the biggest areas
of of areas to focus on
also in the past we used to include the
children who receive
protect and prevent dollars in these
numbers
we used to use child care scholarship
those federal dollars to support those
children
and those are children who are at
involved with the dcyf
or at risk of being involved with dcyf
and need preventative child care
but we move those children out of child
care scholarship
because once a family is in
this might be getting into way too much
detail so i apologize but i think it's
important to set the context is
if a family is eligible for child care
scholarship they're eligible for an
entire year week if their income changes
their circumstances change
we can't take a family out and so that
would be the same for the protect and
prevent child
care so it was better
fiscally for us to have those children
funded differently and not
have to meet the 12-month eligibility
requirement
so a question about this is
any scholarships is this a mix of
of federal and state money and if so
what what portion is the state money
rebecca can you answer that question
sure it is a mix there's um
we have to match part of the grant
dollars
to utilize all the grant dollars
um i just need to look to see
how much i believe it's about 10
million that is state general funds
and about
maybe is it 26 federal
so we have about a 75 match somewhere in
there or a 25
match something like that
let me just get that open
we can continue as we go through these
where there are
uh clear programs and there's a match
requirement
it would be great to highlight exactly
what our match requirement is
and and you know where we are relative
to
uh accessing the federal funds that we
may be eligible for
okay and rebecca we do draw down the
federal funds first correct
um no actually we utilize the general
funds
um first okay so the
federal funds um total 16 million
and we have to match 10 million
okay so we have to come what is i can't
do math in my head is that about a 40
match requirement is that in the
in their rules percent
something um actually it's it's specific
to there's three parts of the child care
development
fund um there's a mandatory that we have
to match
and then there's a matching piece
that we have to match and then there's a
discretionary piece that we do not have
to match
so let's ask you this could you could
you
uh offline create a explanatory document
on some of these on the big programs to
help us
understand what the match rules are
and the extent to which we're we're
taking advantage of them
sure sure and i think too when we go
through the budget
the actual line items that might help
too but we can actually
yeah we can definitely do the um
document
great okay oh was there a question on
that sorry
i'm sorry this is a question by uh
actually two people
so let's go with uh representative
walner and then representative
so um i heard chris i heard you say
that um one reason that we might be
seeing
the child care numbers going down a bit
um obviously they've gone down
during the pandemic but um before that
when did we back out the uh protective
preventive
um children out of these numbers
rebecca was that in 19
i believe it was state fiscal year 19.
and could you tell me how many um
children do you think that was
just just a ballpark of what the uh what
the number was
i don't um have that
right here but let me see
i can get that for you representative
walner
um because i don't oh um we actually
i have it here um
but it's based on dollars not children
um so i can get that for you
great so to be literal there when you
say get that
for representative wallner i i think
what that means for our committee
is that somehow you all get it to mr
ripple and mr ripple
he shares it within the committee yes
yes just just really briefly thank you
chris i can't
appreciate that and i it's the first
time actually
i had really realized that the um
protective preventive we're not we're no
longer in that
employ in that employment figure so it
would be interesting to know
the other question i wondered was i see
on your
chart you're talking about a monthly
average
do you do you keep um statistics i'm
sure you must
on the total number of children in a
year
who benefit from child care scholarship
because
some children may only for instance need
it in the summertime for a couple of
months
yes the number i it would be interesting
to know
how many total children use um
get a child care scholarship in the year
that is something i believe we can get
right rebecca
sure okay yes we can get that to the
committee how is that
great thank you very much yep
verve
thank you mr chairman um i'm just having
a
difficult time understanding this
scholarship
children versus protect him eventually
are these distinct groups so i'm trying
to
um so what there's two different ways
that we fund
child care assistance one second though
now you're talking about funding which
kind of makes sense to me but
it's these are talking about individual
children
correct but we used to include because
the the children who receive protect and
prevent
dollars it used to be
paid for with our child care scholarship
so those children were included in the
monthly
average and the yearly numbers but in
we moved and stopped using child care
scholarship funds for those children
okay okay so those children were
included in those numbers
um and then we stopped doing that
um because of the funding the funding
stream
okay but the children were still getting
dollars to help in this
yes absolutely yes those children and
families and so i'm gonna get
um for the committee how many children a
year
we serve and protect and prevent thank
you
you're welcome it does i apologize it
does get a little bit
um confusing i have a question about
the literal definition of the word
scholarship in this context
okay is this this is up to 13 years old
right and
and this is this is this is money that's
going to date daycare providers to
private schools
to to to to to who for what
yeah the scholars a scholarship to me is
specific money to help pay for academic
development and i'm just curious if
that's what it means here
it it it means it goes to um
child care providers that are either
licensed or licensed exempt
to provide child care
and it goes to the providers to cover
the cost a portion of the cost of the
child care services
so other states call it the child care
development fund
new hampshire before my time chose to
call it the scholarship
program sure i get it
it's a it's a better sounding word so so
my my thought here is um
sort of an age range yeah like like
what percent i would imagine a much
bigger percentage of this
money goes to kids six and under than
seven and up yes you are correct maybe
85 90 is six and under
i can get you the actual breakout
because we do have it broken out i don't
have that handy
but yes i can get that for you and the
children that are in school it would be
after school care
school vacations and summer time
okay thank you okay you're welcome
okay and kevin you write down all these
questions right okay i'm i'm trying to
do it and i'm like i'm gonna miss
something so
um that's super helpful um
and so the um programs that we offer
through this bureau
is um the child care scholarship program
um which we talked about a little bit
um the the quality dollars because we
have to
use 12 of our
grant award has to be used um
for quality initiatives and so
that can be different ways professional
development
qris so there's a lot of different
things that we can do to assist with
quality
we really try to provide resources to
the actual child care providers
we work with head start and early head
start
to really collaborate between those
programs
head start early head start does provide
child care but they also provide
whole family support and other services
for eligible families and then new
hampshire connections
is actually our new child care system
database system that really assists with
families with child care providers
applying online paying for things online
billing online so we're really trying
to enhance our electronic capabilities
with the child care community
as an example when during the pandemic
there was a significant focus on
supporting child care
centers and child care providers to
operate and the department we
through the governor's office through
federal funds
you know we got a lot of money out the
door
to child care providers but we had to do
it in surveymonkey
excel documents because our data system
wasn't able um to meet the demand that
we needed and so we had to do a lot of
emails phone calling a lot of manual
processes
one of the benefits is we were able to
make some enhancements to our new
hampshire connections project
related to covid and now we
have a new 20 million dollar federal
award and all of the awards will be
generated through our it system new
hampshire connections and so
um that's going to be a huge benefit to
the child
care providers as well as our staff
and finance staff processing um payments
so we take credit card payments for new
hampshire connections
well we wouldn't take a payment um it
would be
for a provider to bill um for and then
for us to pay them
yep um
like we mentioned services are provided
um
to children birth to age 13
we work with child care licensing
um very closely and head start and early
head start
provides 48 sites throughout the state
and that is done through the community
action agencies
some of our accomplishments and this is
the one slide i realized yesterday i'm
like i didn't put our accomplishments
um is you know during the pandemic
um we kept child care open um
which was significant i think you know
i think businesses really realized how
critical
child care is to the economy when all of
a sudden
schools were remote
we currently have 768
licensed program which allows for about
forty five thousand spots
we um stood up for emergency child care
programs
um we distributed 38 million dollars of
funds from gopher
and an additional 7 million dollars of
direct money for from
the cares act and then we also
implemented 14 emergency policies to
support
families providers and children so for
example we allowed providers
on that bill for our ccdf scholarship to
go into disaster billing
which enabled them to bill regardless if
the child was there so it was based on
enrollment not attendance
because we knew that child care
providers needed that income
so that they could open again
once the economy started to reopen we
also
and we're still doing this right now we
have covet absenteeism
so when a child care center maybe has to
close a classroom
due to a covet exposure we're
paying for the cost of that service so
that families don't have to pay
um so that's been a huge
support to the child care field
throughout this time we've developed a
new data system
and what we really were able to do is we
offset the cost of this by working with
um the state of massachusetts because
they have um a um
a system that had a lot of the pieces
that we wanted to use and so we were
able to bar
lift and shift some of their codes which
saved us a significant amount of time
and money
and i think throughout this pandemic
we've been working very closely with our
other new england states
to really learn and partner in different
ways
and then we continued to
provide professional development
with um in partnership with the
department of education
um using some of the preschool
development grant dollars
and um we've added new credentials to
about
just over 300 um early childhood
providers so we're continuing
to provide professional development
which is critical for quality
some of our key challenges
i think we all knew
or many of us knew in the field that
child
care is relatively fragile
it is it's not
it's expensive um and so
um and oftentimes families may not have
the right
care at the right location at the right
price
and so i think the pandemic really
showed us how fragile that system really
is
and so one of our challenges is
as well as um the silver lining of covid
is
okay how do we go back once we're post
pandemic but not going back to the way
it was
because the way it was was not meeting
the needs of business and families and
so how do we increase
partnerships at a community level um
so that we can really meet the needs of
those communities and how do we partner
with business
differently i think business found how
critical
child care is to their operations so are
there ways we can
partner with businesses and have child
care centers partner with businesses so
maybe
they assist with some of the costs for
the families that
um that are their employees or they
support some of the needs of child
care um so it also had showed that
you know there needs to be um
more care in infant toddler and family
child care i think
um what families found is smaller
settings
really are meeting the family needs
better and so how do we support that and
expand that as we
um come out of the pandemic um
also um workforce challenges
there was a ch and you're going to
probably hear this across the board with
the department
um some of the direct care workforce
challenges which is included in child
care they have traditionally low wages
oftentimes it's older workers and so
how do we address workforce challenges
for the industry and then a challenge is
also
continuous quality improvement it's
really hard
i think sometimes for child care
providers when
they have really long hours really long
days
and limited staffing how do they then
make the time for
staff development and continued um
staff improvement so those are some
challenges
within um the child development world
um so some of our quality standards um
was that um you know for we have to
provide
um a certain amount of all of
our quality standards um and
we have to for based on the dollars we
spend
we actually have to target some quality
dollars
um for infant toddler um
and um general quality and so
can we skip this slide and i'll tell you
why okay
this is uh this is the first slide like
this in
in the decks that we've seen so far yeah
and this is potentially one of my
favorite slides
of all okay to associate the workload
and the quality standards this way
and as i've looked at this slide trying
to just figure it out intuitively
it makes my head hurt so okay i'd like
to talk to you offline about this if we
could just so
i could really understand there's a
there's a whole lot of potential meat
here
so okay and and that's great yep we can
do that
absolutely and i think it was kind of
you know
different programs have it differently
so um i'm sorry if it made your head
hurt but we can talk
about it okay great thank you
information in my head
um so this is just an overview of the
budget
um with the mix from 2018 to our
current request with um federal funds
and general funds the
these accounting units do not have any
of
any other funds it's either federal um
or general and you'll see that the
federal funds
are the majority of the funds in this
program and we'll go through it line by
line
in a couple of slides
um okay anything on this one okay
um if we had increases
we would increase support for continuous
quality improvement
we would actually potentially look
to expand access to programs that could
be more
steps for child care scholarship it
could be a higher income
threshold which would give families more
access
and really we would look at how do we
address some workforce short
workforce shortages we are working with
other programs um within our department
so the bureau of child development
is working closely with our bureau of
employment supports to say
how do we assist some people who may be
on tanf who have a work requirement
can we do some training to get them into
working with
child care and the same with new
hampshire employment security
how do we um tap into some of their
workers who may need a different job
so how can we do some of that to address
workforce shortages
and then really conversely if we had a
decrease some of those same areas are
areas
um that we would not be able um to
support
so my comment is similar to the other
slide like this
i think i think this is a really great
start
but if you could uh spend some time
thinking about
how this is could be measurable so that
you're telling us exactly what we're
buying or foregoing
sure not a problem
these are all directionally useful but
more specifics on the what would help
yeah okay
not a problem um and then these are the
just the different accounting units
um that we will be going over
i think right now so
so this is where i'd like to uh recess
um um but
i hate to do it because we're probably
what 20 minutes from being done
rebecca i
i could be a little longer is it just
these four accounting units or does this
go on to a second page
uh no it's just these four okay it kind
of depends on
the questions that they have
so so i need to i need to step away and
because we're so close to the
finish um hey
uh representative erf are you
are you ready to step in and i'll step
away
talk later this afternoon about what i'm
missing on the accounting
i'd appreciate it the the big thing i
noticed when i look at the spreadsheet
is it seemed like there were several
accounts where there were no general
funds
appropriated or in the governor's budget
at all
and what the issues are there but
all right uh thank you so i'm going to
step away
and uh representative erf is now the
chair
great and i'm going to turn this over to
rebecca lorden and karen rounds
rebecca just tell me what the first page
um 949.
great so the first one there is 29.76
which
is uh yeah yes towards the bottom here
child development operations
and that goes on to page 950.
so any questions on that
and to the chair's earlier question this
is
it's not a mistake that there are not
general funds here
this should be 100 correct
okay if there's no questions there i'll
move on to
2977 which starts at the bottom of the
page
child development program which is of
course the bulk
of this area so here i do have a
question
um i'm wondering if the
decrease in general funds which appears
to be made up in
federal funds is that the result is are
these funds covered related here
by chance or is this match related what
what
explains that nice benefit to us
sure rebecca i'm sorry what line are you
looking at
the reduction in general funds from
fiscal year um
21 budgeted to 22 and 23.
in the in the county unit 29.77
correct um in the biennium that we're
currently in
there was um several initiatives that we
were
we had to modify our system for um as
well
to align with the federal regulations
and there was
additional general funds given to the
this
division to implement those
it looks like additionally there was
about a million dollars of general funds
that we had to add to this budget i
i happen to remember that 564 was
budgeted at 2 million
for 2020 and that's the protect and
prevent that's children in dcyf care
that need to be paid
with general funds um and
there's a you know a lot of work that's
being done in the dcyf system so we're
continuing to budget that at two million
dollars so that
that one would be a million dollars in
general funds that that increased in
fiscal year 20 there
okay but what i'm really looking at is
between the current year
you have 20 million 21 million in
federal
and the next year you have
this goes on to 16 million but on the
other hand the general funds which were
15 million this which are 15 million
this year
also go down to 11 million are those
why is that going that's a good question
this biennium we've received for
um is sb i believe 570 we had received
funds to modify the system so that we
could get
that that population included in the
child care
there was some other
i think it had to do with the
absenteeism we had to change the way
that we were calculating that to provide
more
absent days there was
the rate we always have a rate increase
i know there was a there was a couple
other initiatives that we had worked
on for um they kind of surrounded the
system
so there was more dollars given to us i
believe there was like
five things um so were those
were those numbers originally budgeted
or were those numbers
because you got more funds like covet
funds or something
no those the general funds were budgeted
they were given to us
in the house phase okay um last
biennium it took us a little
longer to implement some of the things
due to covid
um and we had other dollars to utilize
so i believe we used the
federal funds from some of that um
and that would not be reflective here
any coveted dollars
thank you uh representative wallner
thank you um rebecca i
i am concerned about the
the drop in um
allocation here in 22 and 23
from back to our actual
expenditures in 2020 i mean we're
showing
a total funds reduction of about five
million dollars that would be five
million dollars in services
and last week there was a bill over in
the senate
and i believe you did uh you did a um
a fiscal note for that bill
and actually you were showing that
um it was closer to 33 million
per year that was needed for child
care than it was to 28 million
and i was wondering if maybe um at some
point
you prepare for this division
um like a sort of a fiscal note about
this particular these particular lines
and
i was looking at the one that you did
for senate bill 144
and maybe you could prepare something
like that
for this division so you could see
how you get to um the 33 million as
opposed to 28 million
what i'm worried about here is that if
we
bring this line down and we end up
having
particularly when the pandemic hopefully
lessens and people are going back to
work kids are back in school
and people really need child care needs
are going to increase
that we'll be needing more child care
and this what's in the budget at this
point looks like we'll be having less
available
and we risk a waiting list at some point
and i don't think that's really a goal
here is to have a waiting list in child
care
so i wondered if you could prepare
something that would help us
do sort of a formula through those lines
sure
um did you want me to speak it all
to anything or just um bring you
something back
well i think it would probably be
helpful i because i am sitting here
looking at the fiscal note from
senate bill 144 and everyone else
doesn't have that in front of them so i
think it would be good if at some point
in the next when we're not finalizing
anything today so
if we take some time with this page at
some point in the near future and you
kind of walk through something like what
you did here
for 144 does that make sense
yeah okay and mr earth does that makes
it
uh representative does that make sense
to you call me keith yes
that's fine okay thank you
i guess not okay we'll go down to
2978 which is child care development
quality insurance
which is basically all federal funds
correct um
yeah yes thank you
any other questions there are any
questions there
doesn't appear to be so
all right then moving on to 2979 which
is head start
um state collaboration which
is also 100 federal funds
any questions there
right up here
79 29
is that next uh no i think that's it i
think that's
everything for child care did i miss
anything rebecca
no that's all child care perfect
okay jess is gonna be bummed he hates
when he doesn't when he
takes off and i finish things off for
not doing anything
i'm still here
this was a test oh yeah that was a test
so mr chair i have a question for you or
comment
i i just want to let everyone know that
um i received a request yesterday uh
regarding a couple of our committee
members
being unable to participate fully on the
2nd of march
that's an important day because we have
dcyf that day
so mr ripple who for some reason was
doing work email at 10 o'clock at night
told me that he thinks we can work it
out
and so he and i hopefully this afternoon
we'll take a look at reworking the
schedule
without any commitment my goal is to
completely free up
march 2nd but we may have to
jam a couple of uh days before then to
to be comfortable with that so
so um we'll send uh
information on that um and
representative so i just wanted to thank
you for that accommodation
uh it's a simple thing it's the right
thing okay
all right so you you can close out if
you want there mr chair
oh good so you'll move on with the next
one
is that what you mind uh i wasn't sure
what the plan was do you want to move on
to the next bureau or
um was there i don't know what the plan
was for your lunch break
jess are you still there do you want us
to recess now
oh no i thought you were done i i'm
sorry i i'm trying to pay attention to
this other committee that i'm supposed
to speak
you know i just want you to so we
finished with the number i thought you
guys were done
you should you should finish up your
yourself
we have four other bureaus to cover
right we're finished with the numbers
for that one now we're going to go to
the next slide deck is that what you
want us to do
oh before the next slide deck definitely
go to lunch
so recess now what noon yeah
until noon is that what you're saying
please
okay so i guess we'll be in recess until
noon
all righty thank you thank you thank you
you know i guess
so then it can get everywhere you might
want to leave it there
c
this
yeah i think so i don't know
foreign
um
me
so
hey uh keith can you hear me
so we we apparently run a better meeting
because
um the bill i was supposed to talk about
at 11
15 still hasn't come up
and they've got one more bill before
they get to it
so i'm just going to have a second
computer
looking to see the progress of that
committee and
oh i may cut away for eight to ten
minutes
fine
so so ms rounds
on that on that one slide with
um the the workload benchmarks and the
quality benchmarks
yes i really am excited about the
potential for that slide
okay and so if we could if we could
schedule a meeting
um that meets all of our schedules i i i
would like to spend like 30 minutes
going through that
in depth uh exploring its potential
for other areas so i i
i'm assuming um mr ripple you
and and miss san nello would want to be
on that call
i don't know if there'd be anyone else
i'd like to be on it yes i don't know
about anybody else
i think chris might um have some of her
staff joined as well but i
i do not necessarily need to be part of
that conversation
reach out directly to chris
all right and if you're ready we will go
ahead and nice misspoke before the break
i said there are four presentations left
there are three
that's a good mistake we like that one
all right well um uh
so we're gonna reconvene uh division
three
coming out of recess uh continuing on
with the division of economic and
housing stability
so take it away you're
you're muted chris
is saint nilo you're muted
dave was helping me and i couldn't find
where my controls went so thanks dave
okay can you hear me now yes all right
i hope everybody had a nice little break
so um
i think we're going to go ahead and get
started with our bureau of housing
supports
if that works for everybody um
so all right
so this is led by melissa hatfield and
rebecca lord and again as our finance
director
the bureau the mission of the bureau of
housing support is to end
homelessness in new hampshire through a
collaborative approach to ensure that
all
people experiencing homelessness obtain
permanent housing and self-sufficiency
this is not um in statute
it was developed by this bureau
many years ago
an overview of the bureau of housing
support it assists people who are
experiencing housing instability or
homelessness
to access housing shelter and other
services to assist
to maintain housing stability it
also provides short and medium-term
rental assistance
and permanent supportive housing it
provides
outreach services to those who are
considered hard to reach
oftentimes people who are living on the
streets
and then also through this bureau we
provide
case management to connect individuals
and families
to services including medical and mental
health care
snap and tanf benefits and other
services necessary
um so people can um
maintain their housing
please can i stop you there yeah sure um
i i have assumed that it's it's my
problem
and not being able to find my copy of
your slide deck
um but i'm i'm i'm i'm struggling to
find my copy of your slide deck
so karen
kevin i think i can um
yeah i'll send it to you in an email
representative
all right and then if they're is this
all three of them in this one slide deck
or are there three slide decks
three slide decks okay all three would
be wonderful i don't know why
i can't find them i'm sorry that's okay
um so here um we have the
um number of people served for the last
um
four years um and so
the um the purple line is the total
served
in the state through this bureau and
then
we break it out by the different
programs the yellow is shelter
and then prevention services and then
our continuum of care dollars and then
our emergency solutions grant
um we actually um
have refined how our some of our
services are provided so you'll see that
we weren't tracking the esg services or
we didn't have them back in 2013
and so the continuum of care i'm going
to talk about all of these services but
you'll see
that the majority of the services end up
in
prevention or within the shelter service
system
the annual point in time some of you may
have heard about this
and this is actually what's done each
year the
hud the housing and urban development
requires states to conduct a point in
time
count every year in january
and hud picks the date in january and
that's when
housing programs continuum of care
have to go out and physically count
people who are experiencing
um homelessness and so
this past year um we just did it january
i want to say
27th and we don't have that data yet it
was actually a little complicated due to
covid
but you'll see this here in in january
of 2020 the total number of people
experiencing homelessness was at six
1675. and
um the blue line is
um the 1327 that
those are people in shelters um who are
considered homeless
and then the total on and then people
that are unsheltered is
348 so that was individuals who
were not in shelter they weren't
doubling up they may have been in a tent
um or living in their car and that is
the statewide number
okay some of the programs that we have
under the bureau of housing supports is
we have our programs that are
done in conjunction with the us
department of housing and heart
urban development which is known as hud
we have our balance of state continuum
of care
um and i'm going to talk about that on
the next slide
and those projects provide permanent
support of housing
rapid rehousing and coordinated entry
we also provide emergency solutions
grant which is homeless prevention
and rapid rehousing so it's taking
people
who are homeless and quickly getting
them into
some form of sheltered and then we have
a small on program
that is the housing opportunities for
people with aids which is known as hopwa
and that's really short and long-term
rental assistance
we have our emergency shelter program
which is non-permanent temporary shelter
so um that's for people who have no
other housing options
they'd otherwise be sleeping in a place
that's not meant for human habitation
and and what emergency shelter is really
focused
on meeting the basic needs of each
person
and that is outlined in rsa 120
6a and then we have a
program yep sorry so that's all right
representative earth has his hands oh
i'm sorry i couldn't see
i have too many screens going here sure
okay it's my job to look for okay thank
you
going back to the previous slide
the annual point in time yeah
so unique that was january of 2020 i
believe
correct pre-covert i believe correct
that's a pretty substantial jump like a
increase in at a time when our economy
was booming can you
have an explanation for what was going
on there sure so
um what there's a couple of things that
are going on there
um first of all is we're getting better
and better with our counting
okay um so in january of 2020
the bureau of housing support did a lot
of work
with all of our outreach providers with
the other two continuum of cares to get
really
accurate counts and so we've been
spending
a better time on collecting our data and
making sure we're counting
every person so there was a huge
emphasis on
we need the accurate count so that's one
piece
and the second piece and i'm going to
talk about it a little bit is
while the economy is great the housing
stock
we have a lack of housing stock in the
state of new hampshire
um the vacancy rate i want to say is at
like 1.8 percent
the median rent is
um i think thirteen hundred dollars um
a month and so housing is out of reach
for many individuals we actually have
people who
are working and living in shelters um
because they can't find a place to rent
so those two pieces go in hand in hand
thank you you're welcome um and then
right here oh sorry i still don't have
this presentation
mr ripley i i don't know if it's me but
i
i i don't think i have this presentation
i think i think it is in the email that
i just sent you i think it's the one
label
hs house finance presentation final
okay i checked those three and i
none of those when i open them they they
don't say that so
did you just you did just receive an
email from me though a few minutes ago
though right
did and i responded i believe saying
none of those are the ones
she is sharing i have three you sent
from yesterday however
she's on a different deck i think i
think the one i just sent you looks like
it has six presentations attached
hopefully they all attached and i there
should be one
oh you know what because i only see the
three
i don't see the bottom i don't see the
bottom ones
you need you need a dave wieders in your
house like i have
i do i do all right so
so that's just me not knowing how to
work a an email
it's okay okay
so i'm gonna can i continue yes ma'am
sorry for the interest no it's fine no
no no um and so
finally the other program we have is
through
samhsa which is substance abuse mental
health services and administration
and that funds our assistance
our path outreach and that's for
individuals who have
serious mental illness and this is a
small
um pot of money um and so we get 300
000 a year from samhsa and the services
are provided by
six community mental health centers and
through tri-county community action
um i wanted to take a quick second to
talk about the continuum of care
because um it gets that's a little bit
um
confusing sometimes because the
continuum of care is federal dollars
and it's the goal is to
assist individuals who are experiencing
homelessness to provide services to move
into transitional and permanent housing
and the goal is long-term stability and
so
new hampshire has three different
continuum of care
we have greater nashua which is nashua
and six or seven surrounding communities
we have manchester um which has its very
own
continuum of care just for the city of
manchester and then we have the balance
of state
which is the bureau of housing supports
what's
important to know is each
continuum of care receives its funding
directly from
hud and we cannot um
dollars can't cross boundaries for this
stream of funding
and so um the goal of the continuum of
care
is community-wide planning
to address homelessness improve
coordination
and each community gets to tailor its
program to the strengths and challenges
within that community
and you'll see here that the balance of
state
for new hampshire we got 4.7 million
dollars for the balance of state
on and that is managed by the department
of health and human services
and that is included in one of our
budget um
pieces but i just wanted to point that
out i have a question on this slide
right um so when hud
sends us the money do they send it with
the housing first
restrictions so what hud does
is they um have a goal of housing first
um and then we so that's that that's a
yes
uh so if they do can we ask for
a waiver so that at the discretion of
dhhs
we can waive the housing first
requirements so
and what would we want can i ask why
we'd want to do that
because as i understand housing first
it's
it says that if you have a a congregate
living situation where uh somebody
is um abusing drugs
and is the bad apple spoiling the whole
bunch
and jeopardizing the sobriety and
stability
of the other people in the congregate
living
that the federal housing first program
insists that you leave that bad apple
amongst the others
and when when it may be tough love
but you got to get the bad apple out of
the barrel
so that the other people can survive and
thrive
so it seems like a good intended
program that can actually do more harm
than good and i'd like to
give you the option of waving it when it
doesn't make sense
so i think the so there's a couple
problems with that first of all hud um
releases funds based on housing first as
a priority so
if that if we were to say that we would
lose
critical federal funding because we
would lose
points on our applications i think
while we have housing first as a
goal you know there also are regulations
laws and rules that individuals must
follow
when accessing services so i'd be happy
to talk with you
offline about this particular situation
you might be talking about to see
um if we can clear some of that up okay
okay great thank you
um yeah okay um so this is the delivery
system
um you'll see we provide services
statewide and we have a number of
providers that we contract with and some
of these
providers provide multiple services
and so but i broke it out by the
different program areas
um one of the accomplishments that we
have
um through this past year a couple of
years
we actually really have implemented a
for the balance of
state so i just want to be clear this is
for the balance of state but we
implemented a coordinated entry process
that standardizes access for individuals
who are at risk of homelessness
and experiencing homelessness this has
really helped
individuals and families access housing
services that they need
and it also enables us to prioritize
those who are the most
vulnerable to get access first
also in fiscal year
2019 we were awarded
three new programs rapid rehousing for
stratford county
statewide community entry service system
for survivors of domestic
and sexual violence and we were able to
expand
permanent supportive housing in the
north country so we really tried to
target areas that there were gaps in the
state
and how we could target that and through
the work with the council on housing
stability we're partnering on
submitting a 1915 i medicaid state plan
amendment
and this will enable individuals who
are experiencing homelessness that have
serious mental health diagnosis
or substance use disorder um obtain and
maintain permanent housing
so we're still finalizing that actual
submission
but this will be a way to provide access
to individuals
um to maintain their housing which we're
really excited about
and then we also are looking at creating
a comprehensive case management model
that follows the person throughout the
process
of experiencing homelessness or housing
instability
so if somebody starts an outreach goes
into a shelter and then we can move
into permanent supportive housing the
case management will follow the person
and connect them with the necessary
services
and then finally we have partnered with
our public housing authorities and we've
expanded voucher programs in new
hampshire
so the first one was mainstream vouchers
which provides rental assistance
to non-elderly individuals with
disabilities
so um this will actually help
because it moves people that may be
getting permanent supporting housing
into the public housing
waivers and vouchers which will free up
beds for other
individuals and the same thing for youth
who have left foster care who are
homeless some housing vouchers to incur
to help them become stable
um challenges we have here
um and i touched on it a little bit is
the lack of affordable housing
um new hampshire vacancy rates are 1.8
so that's really low um the data
i have is that in sullivan county
there's a zero vacancy rate
so it's really hard for people um to
move out of the shelter system it's a
backlog because there's
there's a lack of affordable housing for
individuals to move into
one of the other pieces is i mentioned
the rent
rent is 14 13 a month
for a medium typical two-bedroom
apartment and that includes utilities
but that's still out of reach for many
individuals and families
we use state general funds to support
the emergency shelter system and
we reimburse them at a cost of eight
dollars and eighty cents a day when the
actual cost is forty seven dollars a day
um and then finally i think um
the way we access our the way
dollars flow in federal funding is
extremely restrictive and siloed
so it really limits the ability um for
people to be flexible and creative
when trying to find solutions for
homelessness
is there a set of waivers we could be
asking for
to to liberate someone yeah so one of
the things we're working on
actually is i'm glad you asked that is
the council on housing stability is
really looking at
what are some solutions and how can we
one of the goals is to look at how can
we eliminate homelessness and then
another piece of it is what do we need
to look at
as a state and so we're really it's a
very broad council we
were formed under governor um sununu
executive order in
um i think november and so we're
starting to
delve into all of that and really
understand the silos and
other ways we can apply for waivers
restructure how we do things so that's
something that we're um looking at and
we have a report that is due
um in jan in june so hopefully we'll
have
some um strong recommendations that come
out of that
and in your housing program are veterans
treated
like every other uh client or
or is there are there special categories
for
veteran services there's actually some
special funding and special
programs for veterans um and there's a
very large veteran network
walner has her hand up okay
thank you chris this sort of goes back
to the
uh slide before and maybe you have a
slide coming up that has
more detail but i was wondering about
um homeless homeless youth
and young people who find themselves
homeless and
what kinds of programs do we have
specific
programs for those for those people
and yeah how many how many chil
young people do we have um who have left
foster care
that are being served by um your
by one of your programs so i do not have
that data handy as to the number of
youth but i can
actually um get that information for the
committee i'm going to go
back because we actually
and i can get the information um as to
how many
youth are
participating in the housing choice
vouchers we
and we actually statewide we have one
rapid rehousing project for youth that
are experiencing homelessness
and i believe we actually have
under our prioritized needs
expansion of that program and we're also
applying
for the youth homelessness demonstration
project through hud
we applied for it two years ago and we
were not successful
but we are geared up to apply again as
soon as hud releases that
um r of that rfi or rfp
but i can get you that data
[Music]
so could i just ask one more question
yes yes
so i see what i saw on that slide about
the foster
about the um young people coming out of
foster care
was that they get a voucher how much is
the voucher for
how does how does that so
that is um based on
income and so i will get you the exact
dollar amount i'm not sure it's section
8 housing vouchers
so i don't have that off the top of my
head because we don't administer that
um but i can get that for you okay thank
you
thank you you're welcome
[Music]
any um okay so here's your favorite
slide
um representative edwards i think i am
going to love these
okay so um one of so
uh one of the benchmarks that's looked
at is
um hud expects a reduction in the
average length of p
that people experiencing homelessness
okay so
um we in fiscal year 18 it went from
three days
to fiscal year 19 it was 83 days
and so um what we
find is that as the vacancy rate
decreases
level of stay increases right so that's
what i was talking about earlier is
the number of people stay in shelters
longer because they can't get out
and find affordable housing um and so
that's
that's a real issue that we have
because we're held responsible
you know for these benchmarks but yet we
don't necessarily have access to
all of um the housing units that the
state needs and so that
is another area that the council on
housing stability is looking at is how
do we
increase the housing stock because that
is what's going to end
homelessness with the supportive
services for a large majority of people
um hud expen expects that
income for people who are experiencing
homelessness goes
up and we show that from fiscal year 18
to 19
we went up the income went up
so um that's a positive thing
um and that um we
we have to look at the number of people
experiencing homelessness
um from 18 to 19 did decrease
and they expect us to do that for the
first time so that's first time
homelessness not chronic homelessness
and so what's important to know is that
um with all of this the fact that
housing is hard for people to access
this impacts
all of this
i don't see any questions you can okay
all right great thank you
um this is just an overview of our
budgets
um the majority of our funds um are in
federal funds and a small amount
of well you know our request is higher
for general funds
but we do get the majority of our funds
in federal funds
um so what would we do if we had five
percent more um we would increase
funding for shelters
um you know they have um
they have a really hard job and so we
really need to um
provide them with the resources they
need so that they can support um
individuals who are homeless
increase funding would you change that
daily rate from 880 a day
to something higher yes we would we
actually put that in our prioritized
need
we did not jump up to the 45 dollars a
day
but we did put it in i'm trying to pull
it up
um what it is
we would increase it to
um twenty dollars a person a night
so so you're sure that would create
more beds or it would just take pressure
off of the
not for profits that are probably coming
up with the rest of the money
it would it would do a combination
we would look to really
have them increase their capacity to
serve people that are there
provide more extensive services but it
also would enable them to
strengthen their operations
we would also look to expand and
leverage federal funding to increase
populations
for unserved populations we'd increase
some street outreach
and youth services as well as enhance
our case management
and then the medicaid supportive housing
benefit is going to help
us to fill gaps i think sometimes
landlords may be reluctant to rent to
somebody who is experiencing
a mental health disability or substance
use recovering
but if they know that they're supportive
services around the person they may be
more apt
to rent to an individual
and then if we had a decrease
i think there's some smaller shelter
programs
that are really getting by
barely getting by and some of those
would close they are
dependent on volunteers
and so a lot of them are barely making
it by so that
could have them close and then
eviction funding if we had
a decrease and we had to reduce eviction
funding that would really impact people
becoming homeless we want to try to keep
people
in their homes when at all possible
is there any questions on this
oh wait there's one okay
just one yep
two years ago when we were meeting
to go through the budget i i found the
eviction
prevention program to be one of the most
um interesting programs i think that we
were doing it
at the time and because it keep
it it keeps us from having people become
homeless
right and how are we doing on that
program
and how many people are conserving at
this point do you know
so it gets a little um so we've actually
you know um done a lot this past year
especially with coven
right and so i can actually i don't have
it off the top of my head
but i can provide you with the numbers
we assisted people with pre-covered
and then the numbers we did during covid
because
you know we had a number of funds
especially those from gopher to keep
people in their homes
um that was coveted related and i think
off the top of my head
i think we assisted like 4 700
individuals
just with that program and so one of the
things we did over this
past year is we've really leveraged all
of the additional federal dollars that
have come
in um to the state and really moved our
dollars more towards how can we access
the federal dollars first to keep people
in their homes because
you are absolutely correct um we want to
try to keep people in their homes and
do what it takes so that people don't
experience any homelessness
but i can get you those numbers thank
you it
seems like such a good it seems like
such a good use of our
fitted resources to try to keep people
from ending up
homeless right and that includes that's
children and families and
you know you know the stressors of
moving and it's hard to find
housing and so how do we keep people
where they um
in their secure housing thank you
yeah well and it also sounds like this
is a a landlord assistance program
right i mean because the money that
you're
investing is going to the landlord so
that the landlord
has less reason to evict someone
yeah money goes directly to the
landlords
um and so yeah but but we also want to
try to make sure
you know not all eviction is related to
funding
um and so while that's a critical piece
the supportive services are essential to
keep
people um to maintain their um
housing and to provide the tenancy
supports that somebody needs to be
successful
anything else on this slide
okay um whoops
so then um these are just the accounting
units we have
within um the bureau of housing supports
and i think now we're going to
um go over the actual um
budget book or the you know accounting
book
yes is that did i say it right
i try to find it on my spreadsheet okay
so i found path grant good
this is good
okay aaron it's page 966
great thank you so the
the first accounting unit um that shows
on page 966 is actually one that we're
no longer using which is 7925
and um chris or rebecca could you just
let them know why funds are no longer
budgeted there
do we budget somewhere else i'm just
pulling it up actually
this is oh yes we actually move that i'm
um into 79-27
because what we wanted to do is actually
have it be more of the eviction
prevention program this is again one of
those programs that was
siloed within our own department and so
we want to move it under eviction
prevention
so we'll talk about that on the next
page so uh
accounting unit 7926 is the path grant
this
is 100 federal uh grant
any questions on that
well i feel guilty not asking you any
questions just because we're spending
federal money
well you asked me enough questions so i
think i can take some for karen
uh one thing i will mention here
actually we're on this grant that's a
hundred percent
federal um something that you're going
to see throughout the budget
is this change here with funds that are
here in class 102 and are now in class
74.
um as meredith spoke about we have to do
uh sub-recipient monitoring so they're
not just considered contractors there
are contractors who also provide
services on our behalf
and so to better track those in the
accounting system we have moved those
to class 74. so you're going to see that
throughout the budget
okay all right not hearing any questions
i'm going to go ahead and go down to
7927 which is
the housing shelter program which also
continues on to page 968
which is where the the bulk of the
expenditures in order is on page 916.
you have state money here and it looks
like
it looks like the state money from the
prior
budget to your budget is dropping
significantly
is that is that a correct interpretation
and if so
what's happening here yes rebecca would
you
speak to them so in this current um
biennium we were given additional funds
for
um some of the
uh uh sorry um
programs i believe it was a some for
eviction
prevention rapid rehousing outreach
shelter funds
um but because of the pandemic we
weren't able to move forward with
all of it as we had intended
okay so codes are a prioritized need for
us
because we know that the federal dollars
will run
out and we will need those dollars
looks like in the budget though under
the shelter program
we're expecting a a nice huge jump in
federal funds
so i'm confused by that statement it
looks like our federal funds are going
up
significantly and our general funds are
going down in the shelter program
just give rebecca a minute to pull up
that information
like for example in fy 93 it's 7.9
million for the feds
and it's like 3.6 million for
state yeah
i think the federal programs that um
that chris was speaking about too was
the
cares act federal programs which don't
happen within this accounting unit they
when we're appropriated cares act funds
they're elsewhere
i assume this is a match requirement of
state money to get federal money
or is that a bad assumption oh
i'm sorry uh to go back to your question
this accounting unit had been under
budgeted
with their federal dollars so on
each year the grant was just level
funded for the budget
and now that the programs um
we're working better to work with the
vendors
or the shelters and stuff to spend down
the dollars
um and there was some staff turnover and
we've made some
really good changes that we are able to
utilize the full grant so we
um have increased the budget for
the next biennium so that sounds like
good work
yes is there any way we can go back and
ask
retroactively from previous year funds
actually what we've done is um the funds
are
good for two years i believe
and so we're spending the oldest dollars
first
so we're able to carry those into the
next biennium
where we actually have just gone to
increase the federal dollars for the
current
um fiscal year that we're in
thank you and i just want to clarify
that
the federal dollars don't go to the
shelters those are
funded with state general funds um and
so
when we say housing shelter program lots
of things are
included in this in this budget line
but i just want to be clear of that and
then
there is a requirement that hud has that
the
sub-recipient agencies they have to
provide a
you can tell me match uh what the match
requirement here is
uh representative wallner general
wallner now has a question
are there any other questions on 79 26
yeah representative walner does yes
thank you so something that rebecca said
um reminded me of a question i really
it's really a question
for karen and it's beyond
just this page in the budget but they're
like you said that there were a number
of programs
um some in this area that really never
got
up and running because the pandemic and
so we must be lapsing
quite a few funds and i wondered if
karen if you could provide for us
a listing of all those pro of the
programs that we are lapsing
funding from uh
the ones that didn't get up and running
and the ones that got up and running
um late in the budget and
then ended up having addition having
funding left
in their on their lines sure i think
um i can definitely provide that for
fiscal year 20 i'm actually working on a
similar request for the fiscal committee
um for exactly that i mean you will also
see it
as we go through here as you see a
difference from actuals
um presuming that fiscal year 21 budget
was similar
to the fiscal year 20 budget for fiscal
year
21 um of course we're
you know only not even quite
three-quarters of the way through the
year so
what we have are really estimates and a
lot can happen between now and june a
lot could end up contracted between now
and june
so i am working on a similar request for
the fiscal committee
um but at a much higher level just
giving a sense of
what is uh staff labs versus
programmatic labs and i can also provide
that as soon as we
have it um
the other thing i would just mention i
know that
some may be thinking okay the pandemic
started nine months into the fiscal year
but i would just remind everyone that
the budget did not pass
until october 1st so it was only about
three months into the fiscal year
um when the pandemic started so people
were just starting to
you know be in the planning phases and
work towards rfps when um
when the contracts unit started writing
about four or 500 additional contracts
well and at the same time there was a
limited number of providers that could
respond to rfps because they were so
involved in the pandemic yes
thank you i think that the information
you're providing to the fiscal committee
would be really helpful for this
committee to see that same
that same information about which
programs
are lapsing funding and i assume that
we'll have an
explanation of why they're lapsing it
um i think that uh i think the
explanation across the board is
is the pandemic i i don't think that
there's
much of any other reasons other than
that okay
great thank you
any other questions on 79 27
okay and i believe those are the only
two accounting units for this area
so i'm going to go ahead and stop
sharing and turn it back over to chris
for the next area
there's a question with uh
representative nordgren
yeah thank you uh just going back to
mary jane's question
so with the lapses
you're anticipating and
obviously it was last fall into this
year how did that impact the governor's
budget
preparation
do we have any indication
how that influenced any of the decisions
made for funding for the department or
where is that money going
i do think that that's probably a
question you would need to ask
of the governor's office i'm not sure
how our lapses impacted their decision
making
um i yeah i don't know that i have an
answer for that
so that triggers a question in my mind
when you work with the the governor's
office what
what human is that is that mostly chris
elms or who
who do you work with uh no the
governor's office has a budget director
um who is not i'm going to say his last
name wrong son
male you i believe
so matt i believe matt uh presented to
full finance
last week so he would be a good person
to reach out to from the governor's
office
thank you any other questions
i'm gonna unmute you we are going to go
to um the bureau of child support can
you see my screen
okay great thank you um i'm gonna try to
do this without
having um dave because he's in another
meeting so
the mission statement for the bureau of
child support
is that it encourages responsible
parenting
family self-sufficiency and child
well-being
by providing services to locate parents
establish paternity establish modify
and enforce support obligations and
obtain
child and medical support for children
one of the pieces is this while each
state
has its own mission statement
they all are very similar based on
guidelines from the office of child
support at a federal level and then
we end up putting that into our child
support
state plan
um okay the overview
is that child support was created by
congress in 1975
and it ensures that children and single
parent households receive a reliable
source of private financial
and medical support we serve families
from all
socioeconomic backgrounds and actually
we
reach approximately one out of every six
children in new hampshire and on average
disburses
about 83 million dollars a year to
families
it is a it is one of the largest income
support and anti-poverty programs for
children
it reduces a family's need for public
economic assistance
it's been shown federally to prevent
child maltreatment
and with this program um we have a 66
federal match and then plus
which i'll get to later on there's
certain outcomes
and how we perform those outcomes we
actually can receive additional federal
dollars
so i just have to tell you the number
one out of six is just really disturbing
to me
um but that's just that's just a comment
the
the the line above that where it's you
say you serve all
socio-economic backgrounds the word
all uh is stumped i stumble over that
because
i would imagine there are income
thresholds
and not all economic levels
qualify so um
we don't have people qualify if a family
um has a child support order
through the courts um they can qualify
um if a
family says it's much less stressful for
me to have the bureau of child support
collect the child support
than me doing it personally they can
qualify for services
it's not an eligibility program it's an
access to resources
does that help yeah i i
i just i was having a hard time
imagining
uh well-off uh couples or partners
needing the help but well it's not
necessarily the money it's it's
actually getting the resources so if you
are in
a you your relationship ends difficultly
and it's it can be a control thing for
one person to control
funds over another person and this
actually
takes that out of the equation it also
assists with maintaining an accurate
accounting of money in
um so they can clearly say how much
money was given in child support
um and there really there wouldn't be
any questions because we're a third
this is just so party huh well i think
it's just uh
horrible that uh we got one out of six
kids
tied up in these kinds of situations but
again we're getting like but we're also
yeah but we're also getting 83 million
dollars a year to families so that's um
a really positive thing
right i'd rather have every kid happy
and not needing the program but
um
okay thank you um here's our case loads
um we do them every year in september
um and you'll see actually we had an
increase
um or in 2000
um and that was really because we had a
new data system
but really um we our numbers have
declined so i guess um you'll be happy
to hear that um representative edwards
but
i think two things have
caused our caseload numbers to go down
the first one was we had
really high workloads um prior to
2017 and we spent a lot of time on
leaning some of our processes um really
looking at case
management models and really closing
cases that people didn't have time to
close that we really should have closed
so we really went through
um and updated our processes and then
secondly um in the
we had a new agreement with medicaid in
the past
medicaid was referring tons of people to
child support
who didn't want child support services
and so we really refined
that policy so that um
only appropriate referrals come in so
child support was spending a lot of time
with families who didn't want the
services
and so that impacted our caseloads
and then we also um
were able to close a lot of cases during
covid because
you know there was also a decrease in
having to go to court cases they were
able to do stuff telephonically so that
reduced
some of the drive time but also on the
medicaid referrals
really helped with bringing down our
numbers
okay any questions okay
um there are some key stakeholders i
think that's really important to outline
for the bureau of child support
we work very closely with the new
hampshire judicial ban
branch who establishes the legal orders
they establish paternity often if an
order needs to be reviewed and modified
um that's done you know with the
judicial brand we work
very closely on with employers to verify
income and health care coverage um to
garnish wages and then to assist to
enroll children in health care
and then we work very closely with other
non-governmental
agencies we work interstate and
international to
collect child support dollars for
families and we work with our
federal office and national associations
okay we provide our services
across the 11 district offices and then
we have a centralized
intergovernmental and legal unit as well
as customer
service we use technology
enforcement and case management and we
are required
to disperse payments within 48 business
hours of receipt of those payments
we have to work closely with our
stakeholders
employers and then we use
you know methods of establishing legal
fatherhood
including genetic testing we also
will provide across state
collection if one parent resides in
another state or country
some of our accomplishments is
um we're cost effective we collected
nearly 89 million dollars
in federal fiscal year 2020
and for every dollar that is spent on
services
3.93 is collected for families
we have positive outcomes achieved by
children
um because we are able to address
individual needs
services reduce public assistance and
prevent child maltreatment
we also developed and implemented a
five-year strategic plan
and during the pandemic we really
increase
performance due to um the court's
electronic methods
we were really able um to
um continue services uninterrupted
um and we as the courts were continuing
to process child support using telephone
and video methods
it actually resulted in an increase in
participation
um between parents um you would actually
not think that would be the case but
parents who
had to pay child support didn't have to
take an
entire day off from work to sit in the
courthouse
they were able to have a telephone
appointment
and that process really worked on
increasing the number of orders that
were established
so that's one of those silver linings
some of our challenges
is current economic conditions because
high unemployment may impact certain
businesses
so people will actually maybe make less
money
and that'll impact child support that is
given to children
a challenge is always figuring out how
do we
improve the customer experience
how do we use more technology so that
we're
able to get at people um that don't want
to make an appointment that want to do
things online
and really how do we how are we always
looking at how do we improve our
performance
with process improvements autumn
automation
that really is going to help us increase
capacity in our performance
we do actually have um certain um
performance levels and this is
child support nationally has an
incentive system
that measures your performance in these
five areas
establishment of paternity support
orders established
collection of what's owed
cases paying in the arrears and cost
effectiveness
and so because of this
we actually exceed um national
benchmarks um and so each year we
receive financial incentives
um for this and um this has been
um and then we're able to reinvest those
dollars
um into our child support program so
this past year we were able to use some
of our incentive dollars
based on um meeting exceeding
expectations in these areas to assist
with some of the equipment staff needed
to work remotely and so
it's it's a great way because we the
states actually get rewarded for doing
good work that's great we
we have representative earth with a
question oh i'm sorry
hi going back a few slides to number
eight which shows your district offices
i'm just wondering is this another
unique set of district offices or
are these overlapping with some other
operations as well no so we use
our regular district offices that we
have across the state so we
our staff are housed in our district
offices
when you say we oh i'm sorry yes
dhhs yes so in our district offices we
have
child support adult protective services
dcyf the bureau of family assistance and
the bureau of employment support so
we're all
housed in those offices okay now do the
idn's
come under dhhs in terms of the are you
sort of responsible for them
i'm not responsible for the idn's no
that would be
under um medicaid and behavioral health
and they have seven regions right it's
it's how many regions does the state
have to have right
um okay but my question is so when you
answer the question about what you have
you just meant specifically
beneath you i'm talking about dhh
hhs as a whole how many different
combinations of just of of
mappings do they have if you will to the
state so i'm going to look to see if
karen is still on the the areas that i
use
primarily follow district office
catchment areas but there are a number
of the public health which they'll talk
about has
public health networks um the area
agencies and community mental health
centers are broken up into 10 areas
so i think the physical locations of our
offices in the state
are the the district offices and those
include staff
from this division from dcyf from
division of long-term supports and
services
the contractors that we have or the
sub-recipients that we have
they may have different catchment areas
or different
models that cover different areas like
the public health networks or
the dd system like chris mentioned but
they do not
utilize our district offices with their
staff
they have their own offices with their
own staff
our staff are at the district offices
okay so there's no way to make them not
necessarily identical to you or whatever
it is 11.
but to follow the same lines so
that is a larger question i i wish you
had asked that when the commissioner was
here
something that she um has some strong
feelings about as well and something
that
she would like to um
to have the department look at in a
strategic planning
um okay in a strategic way
um but that's not something that's
you know uniform right now well i know
that
thank you you're welcome
um so this here actually
shows you um our different performance
measures um in the different areas
that we talked about on the previous
slide and i wish that we actually had a
side by side on this one
um so you could see that you know this
is
our increases in the
paternity establishment that actually
while our numbers went down a little bit
in
this past fiscal year due to the
pandemic we still were higher
than national standards and so for a
period when
some of the offices and you know out
laboratories and stuff
were closed down our numbers went down a
little bit but then
but we we still exceeded performance
nationally which is
extremely beneficial because
some of the other new england states
weren't as successful as we were and
they
actually are going to be losing some
dollars based on that
we actually continue to um
increase support orders and
child support paid paid so
we did actually um
receive more money in fiscal year 20
because
of some of the economic impact payments
we were able to assist that
with um payment of the on the arrears
as well as unemployment on benefits
any questions okay
maybe i got
the calls i get that have the most
emotion and passion in them are the
calls that are related to people caught
up
in the child support system and and
they're going to war with their their
partner
over things related to the the kids what
decisions of the court decisions of dhhs
you know complaints that a paternity
test was established on one kid but not
the other three
you know uh stuff like that so i'm just
curious
if there's a metric or any tracking
being done on
um customers i hate to say it that way
but customer satisfaction
or or or the extent to which
uh because i i saw that was one of your
challenges something you want to work on
but but are there any measures in place
to sort of track um satisfaction with
the
with the system yep um and so
i'm um that's something we always want
to look for and you know and one of the
pieces
is you know we don't put um
um the orders in place right we are
enforcing some orders that are
are done through the court system and
oftentimes there's lots of emotions and
there's lots of
complicating factors our current it
system does not allow us to track
customer satisfaction
but that is one of the things we're
looking to improve with some of our
incentive dollars
um karen who is the bureau chief and i
have talked and
you know that's one of the things we
want to look at with our
incentive dollars also you know the
child support guidelines that's done
through um rule and statute and so
um it is something that um
we need to look at holistically
how are your employees doing in this
area is this an
area where you have a lot of attrition a
lot of stress a lot of burnout
or are they pretty well shielded from
uh the public sentiment so
again you know um it is a stressful
job um i have to say but they are
very dedicated and very committed to the
goals and the outcomes of the child
support program we
um provide a lot of um support
um to them and there's very little
attrition within this part of the
division
um yeah
thank you you're welcome
okay um this is just a little bit here
about
our funds like we said it's um
33 um
federal i mean general funds the rest
are 34
sorry um fed general the rest is
um federal dollars um and
we have a small amount of other funds
which is our incentive funds
so this trend there has shown that
we're increasing the percentage of
state dollars uh over each budget
but and our federal money isn't growing
as fast
a little bit um some of the federal
dollars and i'm going to
defer to rebecca on some of this is that
we
actually are budgeting less incentive
funds so that we can use those
as we move forward
that was one of the pieces with our
incentive funds and i'll let rebecca
talk about that a little bit and then
some of the spending we
had with our incentive funds because of
covid delayed some of that work and so
some of that
is being moved forward into our next
fiscal year rebecca
did you still have a question
representative
i guess i'm just looking at the three uh
bubble charts here in the red
and each each uh budget we're increasing
about 1.2 million
or more each year and so
so that's a that's a pretty rapid
significant increase in state funding
and i'm so i'm just
i'm just curious what what's what's
driving
that growth rate
so there was i think it was
it was this biennium on our
nexus system wasn't supported through
the capital budget
so the prior biennium we
used incentive funds to keep enhancing
the system
and this biennium were in we
switched those dollars so that it was
general funds and the federal funds
instead of using the incentive dollars
so that we could use the incentive
dollars to try and
enhance areas that we weren't able to do
previously so
it almost sounds like you're describing
these incentive monies going somewhere
where the legislature doesn't have
visibility over it
so but i'm sure that's not true that's
not true
i think it's really trying to yeah it's
trying to do things like we talked about
with customer satisfaction
and really not have it be for general
um operations and and maintenance of the
system and so by
including some of the nexus into our
um main you know our maintenance and
operations we're able to actually get
some of the
66 federal match on that um
which is very helpful
the um incentive buttons are not
supposed to
supplant funds it's supposed to
be able to enhance the program
okay
okay any other questions uh yes
representative
i'm having a hard time hearing okay
um i have two questions one on the
previous slide can i just assume that
bigger
percentages are better back on the key
performance indicators i'm just not sure
what ivd pep means
oh sure yep yep it's um it goes to
establish yes
absolutely that is the paternity
establishment and then the next one is
establishment
of um of the
court orders percent of child of
received paid and then the percent were
paying on
the arrears so it's our um yeah
i can send you the actual acronyms i
apologize
no that's okay i think i have the list i
just didn't recognize it okay
but the real question is on your current
slide
yep this one that one i'm looking at
the spreadsheet not the book so maybe
this is
shouldn't add up but
you show for instance 22 23 9.9 million
for general funds
and the general funds and i assume
that's the budget correct your budget
amounts rebecca yes
4.0 roughly a million in
22 and 4.3 million roughly in 23
which is way less than 9.9 i'm just
wondering am i missing something
this is um the agency phase
request we um
the budget was reduced there's a couple
of unfunded positions
after the governor's space okay so
here's another question for you then
same question but for the previous for
the current biennium
20 20 2020 and 2021 you show up 8.4
million and yet in both
years in the governor's budget for
showing the actual 20 and the adjusted
authorized 20 they're less than 4
million each
so a total of under 8 million in other
words i'm just wondering again
so we took um so for that
uh chart it's the actual 420
and then 21 is adjusted authorized
that's what i gave you but the
adjustment
price is just under 4 million 9.3.978
and the actual 120 is uh 3.841
million um may ask are you looking at
one accounting unit or are you looking
at the whole
um program i'm looking at 79.29
is that okay there's more um
programs with that there's i believe
four accounting units
that pick up the total well okay that
aren't that weren't included in this
presentation
right no all four of the accounting
units are on
oh
yes so this this represents all four of
those okay
thanks i i don't know if this
matches up against the um what's in the
spreadsheet for the budget because i'm
looking at child support services in the
spreadsheet
and in fy 22 and 23
the general fund is 4.084 million
and then the next year is 4.275
so that's about an 8.3
total but i'm seeing 9.9
in the red there in the bubble chart
so um are are these
did numbers match i guess is the
question i think that's the same thing
that representative earth was speaking
about that
you may just be looking at one
accounting unit all four accounting
units totaled
um even in the governor's phase are nine
point two or three okay
so so the issue is with the headline of
this slide where it says bureau of child
support
services budget it's more than just
this activity name child support
services
i just figured it out it's actually the
the the column before
which says child support services
basically has four components of which
we were looking at one of those four
which also has the same name child
support services
correct those kids they need a lot of
support
right all right very good
thank you okay so
um again the um
five percent increase decrease would be
um
you know we would obtain better outcomes
for children
meaning getting more resources for
children
reach parents who are not yet using
child support services there may be some
parents who
are in need of the services that aren't
aware of it um and really look to
enhance our tools for better customer
service so that people can do
more stuff online off hours um
and do more self-service
decrease would be a delay in
families receipt of needed support we
also
would risk not being in compliant with
our federal time frames and other
requirements which have financial
penalties
and then also fiscal penalties for poor
performance
if we don't pass our data reliability
audit
i mean also earlier i talked about the
incentive funds that is really
additional
dollars that um we use
to do some of those um enhancements to
our
service delivery system and that would
be impacted
okay so you know from my previous
comments
yeah this this line that says obtain
better outcomes for children
if you could somehow make that
measurable yep
i will do that okay and we will get that
you send them sounds like you added a
fourth
decremented budget outcome by by saying
we
we might miss out on federal incentive
money
yes is that really your third box that
really
you know um falls into the third box um
but um and we will provide all of that
to you
um in writing because i think um
you know um it'll be easier that way
definitely
you're welcome um and then these are the
accounting units um that make
up those circles on two slides ahead
so um that will
we'll walk through that when we go to um
walk through the budget book and then
um here's just a break out of the staff
we have 127
positions um and this is how they're
broken out
by program support supervisors
and child support officers
okay how's your voice holding out you've
been talking a lot
that's what i do i'm italian so i talk
really well
um i have to say and i can go on and you
can't even see my arms moving all the
time so um you're really lucky at that
point so
i'm going to now turn it over to rebecca
and karen and i'm going to have
some water i think so
page 969.
as you saw in the presentation from
chris uh there are four
accounting units in this section
starting with 7929 as rebecca just
started starting on page 969.
i think i have a question here i'm i'm
looking at
um expedited ivd services
and it looks like uh
we're getting federal funds of just
under 900 000.
and then um i think that's a later
accounting unit
that's not that's 79.34
i jumped ahead to ivd i'm sorry i i just
it jumped out at me it's okay
so um so so we don't spend any
state money on paternity tests
it's all federal is that
is that am i reading this spreadsheet
correctly that
ivd services their funding is all
federal
um um are you looking at the accounting
in it 7934
yes that's actually um
that's for uh the courts
it's um we have a contract with the
administrative office of the courts for
the marital masters
they hear cases and they get reimbursed
for um the federal portion so
it's it's a hundred percent federal
i could have sworn earlier on the
performance slide
with the bar graphs that ibd
was for paternity testing but
but that's okay and it just
i i i'm just a little confused because i
thought
ivd on the bar chart was
um yeah right there
that's what it's referred to because
it's the title of the social security
act so
a couple of pieces um are it governs the
program
for us so that's how they refer to it
all right so so maybe
somebody in the committee could train me
later because i'm i'm confused it looks
like
this is all money to pay for the pay the
court
for the court activities
but in the performance chart it was
described
as paternity testing or paternity
establishment
it's not a lot of money and it's federal
so let's move on
i just uh it just it just seemed like
we're using different descriptions of
the same letters
ask a question yes
what are indirect costs line 40
i believe that uh mr ripple provided
the information from department of
administrative services on class 40.
um so i haven't sent that along yet
an email to you all later today it
may be posted to our website though i'm
not sure yet
it is posted with the website okay
and perhaps related to justin's question
is it possible that there's some of that
paternity stuff
in the main 7929
rebecca do you know exactly what class
line we pay them to assign
we do pay it out of the contracts line
um and some of it it's paid yeah it's
paid out of 102.
does that make sense jess yes
so we don't spend any state money to
establish paternity
is is that a true statement
um we do pay the 34
general oh general funds and then it's
matched federal
this accounting unit 7929 does have
general funds in it
ah all right very good
any other questions on 79.29
okay the next one is
uh 7931 which is the
state disbursement unit
what what is that
who do we contract with us um
is it conduit
i believe trying to unmute myself yes
they um they disburse
the funds they receive them and disperse
them
we're required to have that that a place
where funds are received
disbursed um and distribute the payments
and it interfaces with our child support
system
so is that a cost or just for money
flowing through
it's a cost for to pay the contractor to
transfer those funds
which ones are they paying all across
the entire department or
no this is just the child support fund
so chris how many how many
millions a year are paid in child
support like 83 million dollars a year
so this is this is the it system to
to manage making those 80 million
dollars a year in payments
within two days of receiving them well
that's a good time out with this with
the high
turnaround
okay okay
all right moving down to 79.33
access and visitation it's a hundred
thousand dollar federal grant
and lastly in child support is 7934
which we were just speaking about
earlier
any questions i don't i don't see any
okay yes just so you know when you turn
to the side there
and kind of move your head a little bit
away we lose you
automatically i should lean in like this
then
you don't need to lean that far in it's
just when you sit back and turn your
head that we kind of lose you
okay thank you so
um chair if i might um is it possible
that we
i could request a five minute break this
last presentation is about 25 slides and
it's about
uh 15 accounting units so i expect it'll
take more than an hour so i'm just
thinking
um
so we'll come back it's 126. uh let's
come back at uh 135
recess to 135.
uh
you
so
hey representative erf you got your hand
up did did you have a question to start
the
uh when we get back from recess or is
that now
no i just put that up i just want to ask
karen a quick question before we start
the next one if you don't mind
all right sure
um the the ones in a lot of the fields
in the 20 79 29 we just looked at what
are those
one dollar um
yeah they're just placeholders so that
the class lines don't have to be created
if they're budgeted at zero then the
class lines have to be
created to transfer funds into them
um so is that another way of saying that
if they're zeros they go away yes
and then we have to get them recreated
which creates some problems
rebecca correct me if i'm wrong but i
think where we did do that
we budgeted one dollar as a federal
dollar as a placeholder not a general
fund
correct okay yes so if we if you
eliminated those that would eliminate
only federal funds there's no general
funds in those
class lines that we budgeted a dollar
i mean there's never general funds or
just right now there's not
right now right now there's not when we
use the one dollar as a placeholder
we budgeted as a federal dollar as a
placeholder not as a general fund
right but if you go to use it you could
put general funds into it
correct but they would have to come from
somewhere else so they would get
transferred from a different line
right right yes
you had a question i guess i guess we're
out of recess and
we're running again go ahead no
i just i just um picked up my husband
just picked up my mail
and in the mail today was the budget
briefing book
that i brought karen put together and i
just want to say thank you
and it looks really very thorough and
has lots of good information in it
you're welcome it might be a lot of work
i passed that thank you
on to uh the directors and the finance
directors who worked on that
um it was very much appreciated we um
we did not we were not able to provide
fun for the governor's phase
um so i'm thrilled that we were able to
get one for for this
phase so it is really helpful thank you
okay so miss santinello
how are your arms are you ready to start
waving your hands against
i am and here i go so we are going to do
the um bureau of family assistance and
the bureau
of employment supports together
programmatically
they are separate but they are very
closely aligned
um and so because of how the money flows
and all of that it makes a lot of sense
to do them
together um
okay
go ahead okay great so um the mission
statement for the bureau of family
assistance which was made by the team
it's not
in statute or rule is to provide value
services and supports to assess
children individuals and families
towards upward
social and economic well-being
to overall decrease the need for
assistance by
providing services and supports in the
areas
of employment family well-being and
barrier removal
and with the bureau of employment
supports um it's really to assist
parents with upward economic mobility
by promoting work um through the
provision of employment support and
training services
in an effort to strengthen families and
improve child and family well-being
again this was done by the team not by
statute or
rule so when we get into the
right spot around that would would you
make sure i understand
the distinction between your role and
the role over
in uh dehs or whatever the employment
services group is
because they they have a training
responsibility
statewide we have 12 or more
training programs and so i can get into
that a little bit but
um rich lavers and i actually we we work
very closely and our
end is while it is on some of the
employment
pieces of it a lot of it is barrier
reduction and so
providing some of the supports so then
somebody can
participate in some of rich's programs
um at employment
um security and he and i have talked a
lot about
you know and unfortunately covet kind of
really you know
got in the way of doing some planning is
how can we
bring our services better together and
streamline
and build off of the strengths of each
and not have duplicative services so
that is definitely on my radar the term
barrier support or removing barriers
i think has shifted over the last i
can't hear you i'm sorry
oh i'm sorry i i said i think the
term barrier reduction or removal
is probably varied over the last 20
years what what
do you think it currently means well so
it depends right so
for some individuals it could be
reliable transportation
and so i'm going to talk about that a
little bit later um others
is access to child care sometimes it's
just
the money to pay for credentialing or
in other instances it's access to
mental health services or substance use
services
or domestic violence support so um some
of those things and how do we connect
people to those so that they're
successful at work
yep so the bureau of family assistance
primarily is the focus is to gain access
to supplemental
nutrition programs which we call snap
medical coverage
some of our state supplemental programs
which we'll talk about
on the tanf program and child care
scholarship
with really the focus to ensure that
adults children and families have access
to health care
nutritious food child care and financial
resources
bfa also sets policy and program
implementation
for the snap program and for the tanf
program
the bureau of employment supports which
we just referenced
is really it's the work on program for
individuals who have tanf
and snap utilizing a whole family's
approach to jobs framework
it nhep works to provide parents with
the employability
skills that will result in establishing
careers and
ultimately will help move children and
families out of poverty
some of the work they do is to ensure
participants gain employment
have an understanding of community
resources
obtain certain life skills to
balance work and family and then really
focus on an identified career pathway
we'll work with laborers and educational
training organizations to address labor
market needs through training
we focus on training opportunities to
assist parents in gaining employment
credentials
so for example recently within our
division
the bureau of child development
met with the bureau of employment
supports and said okay
how do we provide resources
so that individuals who are on tanf or
snap will go
into the child care field how can we
take some of the resources that we have
for education
and help generate more workers in the
child care industry
in a couple of weeks we're actually
meeting with a non-profit organization
that's really looking at their workforce
and workflow
and the bureau of employment supports
along with
um the department of employment services
were both meeting with the agency to say
all right how do we frame our services
so that
we can provide you with some
resource resources for
employees
here we will um
these are the case loads we have
for the different programs under
the bureau of family assistance and
you'll see
we have here for the different fiscal
years the first one is
tanf which is the cash assistance and so
on one side you see the case load
numbers
and on the other side you're going to
see the average
monthly grant the families
with dependent children um
i think that's the right i always mess
up that acronym
um that is tied um to tanf it's a
relatively small number
we have the interim disabled parent
program
which again is tied to our tanf the old
age assistance
aid to the and and i should back up the
flock
and idp that goes towards our tanf
moe and then we have old age assistance
aid to the needy blind and aid to the
permanently and totally disabled
which goes to our medicaid maintenance
of effort and these are the
um numbers of individuals
in these categories and the monthly
average
grant that individuals receive while on
this program
any questions okay
um and then here is the actual um
monthly grant for for fiscal years 18
19 20 and what we've have budgeted
um for 2021.
yep that's fine i'm gonna grab my other
sheet of paper too hold on a second
okay
i can't hear you i'm sorry oh you can go
okay sorry um and here's where we are
with
what we budgeted in fiscal year 20 and
our actual expenditures
in fiscal year 20. you'll see that aptd
we actually spent more than we budgeted
and tanf was down a little bit so um
there there's fluctuations within um
these um case load types
can i go ahead or yeah just just go on
listen
until you say something okay um and
here's where we are budgeted
um there we go representative
sure uh chris
at some point could we get a report
about how much is in the tanf reserve
fund mary do you or karen do you want to
report on the tanf
balance
sure um the tanf balance is currently
around
40 million dollars um we expect it'll be
a little bit lower than that by the end
of the fiscal year
um but that's where it currently is it
is quite a bit higher than we estimated
it
was going to be this biennium when we
talked about it last biennium we were
coming close to we estimated that the at
the end of this biennium it would be
around
14 or 15 million dollars um
two things that have affected that the
most one is case loads being
lower than anticipated and uh chris
could speak to why case loads might be
lower than we anticipated
and um second being that we did
not use tanf uh tanf was not needed
in the child care budget um which
i think was budgeted several million
dollars a year so that
um increased the tanf
balance as well and we also karen
reduced the contracts that we were
paying out of tanf
and um as a whole in the department
and we really focused on you know those
that met the four goals of tanf um
to really streamline what um contracts
we use
that funding for and chris can you speak
to the tan of caseloads being lower than
intel yeah
so um this is actually um it's it's
actually interesting
because i've been working on this our
numbers are lower and
what was kind of fascinating
to me is last night i was starting to
get emails from the other new england
states
um and we do a lot of that right like
what do your numbers look like and they
all have lower tanf numbers
and everybody's trying to figure this
out because we're in a
we have you know an economic crisis with
covid
you know so what's going on so what
there's a couple of things that are
happening
um the first piece is that
with tanf um
a number you have to be working to
access tanf there are certain work
requirements
and so um while unemployment is
up people are actually making
getting more money with unemployment and
the federal
assistant federal unemployment so that
they're not necessarily needing the tanf
money
also we've been providing a ton of
resources
through our snap program federal
resources for
pandemic ebt which provides
cash assistance snap dollars for
families who
have kids who are getting free and
reduced lunch or eligible for
we've been providing the maximum
allotment
for snap benefits which is a federal
program
we also have people who um have been
receiving the economic stimulus payments
so a number of people
um either aren't
applying for tanf right now we actually
had some bumps where people applied when
unemployment went down
when there was a gap but we have not
seen increases
we do feel and we believe
that once the additional unemployment
goes away
once the um snap benefits go back to
pre-pandemic there's going to be an
increase of
people applying for tanf um
it's just something that we we're kind
of waiting for that to happen and we've
been waiting for it actually throughout
the pandemic
but at this point it doesn't seem that
people are
applying because they're not needing
other resources right this minute that
doesn't mean that
in three weeks four weeks a month people
are gonna need those
you have a resources
uh representative uh weiler
mr chair fwoc families with older
children
how old what are the age limits and uh
how do they qualify
so mary police can you jump in because i
messed this one up all the time
or dead
your hand is still up do you are you
going to have a follow-up or is that
just
good afternoon i'm sorry could you
repeat the question
yes families with older children qualify
for some programs
what are the ages to be older children
how what's the range of ages and how do
they qualify if they have older children
they have to be in high school
and i believe it's up to age 19 but it
may be
20.
but they do have to be in high school
and so why do they get help
i would have to go back and research
that representative
obviously there isn't there isn't
anywhere near the numbers every
program so so you specialize for some
reason
anyway thank you we can go back and get
the history for you
um i believe it was a way to help
families transition
slowly um off of tanf while they still
had children in high school
but we can go back and get the actual
when the program was established it is a
relatively small number
normally if you're a family getting
assistance
and the only child you have possibly
achieves the age of 18 which is
supposedly a legal age
so they that would not be counted then
other than this program
in other words you're no longer children
right this just but the child unless
they're still in high school and you
still have needs
right so these are they have to still be
in high school
okay that's the um piece it's the
it's really the high school component
which allows the eligibility in this
program
thank you you're welcome
can i go well no we have a couple
questions okay
this is a great slide we got everyone
going now good uh
well then don't don't turn mary kalis
off then because she has the wealth of
information
representative norgren
you're on me
sorry um is this one of the programs we
raised to age
uh last time i think
there were some programs that were 16
and i think we raised age is this
one of them in the in the last budget
yeah no not in these we've actually
haven't raised
the age in these that i'm aware of okay
must have been another program thank you
you're welcome the dcyf program we
raised the age for
the legislature to raise the age for
foster care
okay thank you
representative yes thank you
it looks like in your case loads fy21
december 2020 actual your total column
is a copy of your pit case load
column
on the previous slide it does look like
there's an error there
on the tana row well another column the
under the total column and the under the
blue
yeah i'll have to uh fix that
thank you
oh i see okay
but it's consistent yep right are there
any other questions
all right so you're you're free to
continue i'm free to click
okay um whoops all right
um and here just is um our snap on
caseload that's this doesn't
we get lots of questions about this um
and so i just wanted to put that in here
um the um snap um
we had an increase in expenses because
we created
a lot of snap benefit programs emergency
allotment pandemic ebt
plus there was a 15
increase in benefits so i just wanted to
show
you um the average caseload we still
are not seeing a huge increase in
snap due to the pandemic early on
in the pandemic the additional hundred
dollars
was um counted towards snap and now the
additional unemployment is not
counted in snap um but i just wanted to
include this in the slide deck
so yep you mind if i ask a question nope
so the costs shot up and i understand
what you just said
does that was were those funds coveted
funds
there so rebecca can yeah these were all
covered related for
the um emergency allotment pandemic ebt
and the increase in our benefits yes it
is not
does not impact us so just kind of a
general question
how would we see how the coveted funds
were accounted for
do they not appear in anything we're
looking at here either historically or
going forward
rebecca and karen
you're going to see the covet in here i
believe
in 21.
i believe it's just go ahead karen sorry
i was just going to say most of our
coded funding we put into separate
accounting units
um and so because we're not continuing
to budget those those would not show up
in the budget
so can you just get us an account of the
1.2 billion dollars
roughly uh so if you're talking about
the 1.2 that gopher received
gopher would need to provide that for
you i can provide for you
what um the department received okay
that's why that's my legacy okay this
year the
fiscal year i believe the 20 and 21
are the um coveted related um funds
for snap benefits me i mean generally
across the whole
yeah hhs chris could i please add that
we don't budget the snap grant dollars
at all that we have administrative
oversight of the letter of credit
but that we do not include the dollars
paid for food stamp benefits in our
budget
the vendors square up with the
contract provider and the contract
provider squares up with the federal
government
and we monitor that activity thank you
okay can i go is it okay to go to the
next slide
could i just could i just
[Music]
um representative irf i was going to say
you can look at
um how the gopher funds how all those
funds at two point that 1.25
billion dollars was spent by going to
the gopher website
and also um the lba has been tracking
them
and um they they might be able to
provide us with a uh
with a reporting of the um
how those funds all went and were used
in the state
thank you you actually i can send out a
link on our website we update weekly
uh a spreadsheet of all federal covert
funding it's not specific to the
department it's statewide and it may not
be down to the level of detail that
you're looking for but i think you may
find it helpful
i'm can i and can i go to the next slide
okay thank you um and this here is just
the numbers of people served in the new
hampshire employment program
and there's a direct correlation because
this
program focuses on individuals receiving
tanf
um so a decrease in tanf numbers would
result in a decrease
in new hampshire employment program
and so that's why there's been a
decrease
during 20 and into 21.
and i would just add that the increase
that you see from 17 to 18 if you
remember
when we presented the department-wide
presentation there was a change in tan
of eligibility
and who is eligible from 17 to 18 during
that legislative session
so that's why the numbers increased
there thank you karen
you remember generally what the nature
of the
changed eligibility was
we could get that for you it was in
legislation
i don't remember the exact amount of the
change
do any of the legislators remember what
the changed eligibility was
uh how long ago it would have been
during the
2017 session because it became effective
in 18.
there was one way we changed if there
were two parents in a household
who was treated differently than ever
was single
this was actually an increase of the
tanf um
grant and i don't have the exact
percentage um that we went
up i don't know if mary kalise has it
but
i might have it on a piece of paper
um or rebecca might know but i can get
that for you yeah we can get that far
mary's on another call
right now okay but we can
find it for you i can get that as well
two from 2017 i think okay that'd be
great kevin thank you
because it changed the amount of the
tana grant but it also changed the
uh the federal the ffp percentage
so it changed the number of people
eligible as well as the amount they
received
yeah thank you
um all right um so just um
a little bit about bfa um these are the
programs it
really the is access eligibility access
and determination for these programs
here
that is primarily on top of the policy
work on that bfa
um does and then when we move to the
bureau of employment
supports they provide
tanf recipients are required
to participate in a work program so in
order to continue
to receive assistance for tanf you need
to participate
in a work program and so here's some of
the resources that we provide
in addition to connecting people with
other
work programs within the state
so career guidance these are some of the
barrier reduction services that we
will be providing and we also partner
with
businesses such as like cbs
around getting people into career
pathways
and working on some of those barrier
reduction services
and then we also have a program for
individuals who are on snap
which is the food stamps and that's a
voluntary program
and that's really helping people
obtain jobs such as job search materials
resumes assistance with transportation
to help people access employment who are
on snap
so if uh if refugees
get ebt cards is that under this or is
it somewhere else
if a person if a refugee receives an ebt
card they're either getting snap
benefits or
tanf financial assistance
is was that the question yes
okay i was just curious if there was
another because earlier
uh in all of these briefings we covered
a refugee
uh budget line uh and i just was curious
where the ebts would be budgeted
it sounds like montana for snap and not
back in the other account
i'm going to double check on that
because i do know we have a couple of
small
um programs that are targeted um
and that may be one of them and i
actually think
um i'm i'm thinking out loud which is
always dangerous for me
um that there's actually some
pass-through money
that comes through um into bfa to
provide supports for individuals um
on that with the um refugee cash
assistance
so so the related background question
around that is are we
are we properly anticipating the
increase in
refugee population that's expected in
the next couple of years
so i will have to get back with you on
that um i don't have the answer to that
but i can get that information
okay all right i'm gonna
um service delivery um we provide
services
through our district offices and so um
we have staff in all of the 11 district
offices we also have some centralized
units here in concord
all services through bfa are done
through
state of new hampshire employees in
addition to coming into a district
office
we do phone interviews we do phone
appointments
and we also have new hampshire easy
which
allows people to apply and access their
benefits online
and manage some of their services the
bureau of employment supports are also
provided
statewide and it's a combination of
our own state employees in the district
offices
and also some contract services through
southern new hampshire services
but we have statewide access
some of the accomplishments over this
last year
is to be honest with you within
this program area we transitioned to
working fully
remote without any disruption to
individuals receiving services when the
pandemic
you know first hit we started to reduce
foot traffic in the district offices
because there's a lot of people that
come in and out of the district offices
and so we reduce the number of people
coming in and then we transition
to remote and and people
are are still able to apply and we've
received a number of waivers from our
federal partners
to allow allow us to do appointments by
phone
um we do receive faxes you know
email online um everything we were able
um to do we were able to do remotely
and so we have continued to do interview
appointments
on the phone and then face to face if
requested and if um needed and then
one of the benefits of this actually is
individuals have increased their use of
new hampshire easy
which is much easier for people to
upload their information and access
their benefits
um we representative erf has a question
are you getting a good break spot
sure do you see that continuing
post covert if we ever get there the
reminder
working remote um so it's it's funny
um because i can remember meeting with
staff
like two months before the pandemic
right and so
saying oh we would love the ability to
just work at home
once in a while um and we kind of
laughed i'm like i'm with it
but it's probably going to take us a
couple years to get there and then
three weeks you know we were able to
roll it out i
i don't we're never going to be in this
area 100
remote but i do think we will be able to
look at
um some hybrid models because there is
value with people being together in the
office but yet
there's also value with people being
able to do certain aspects of their job
remotely
and we've worked through all the kinks
of um
how you know the the systems work
because they're pretty um
complicated but um we're always gonna
have to have people have the ability to
come into district offices and meet
one-on-one with people because that's
really essential
um but i think we'll have some type of
mix
um when we're out of this does that
allow for space reduction
um that is something we actually have
talked about um and we've talked about
with facilities that
you know we might not need as much
bricks and mortar and have maybe more
shared space
that is something we're looking at
so are you looking at it hard enough to
where we can reduce the rents budget for
the next
two years probably not um and that's not
something that you know that's what
something we'd be doing
in conjunction with facilities um
and um uh kevin kevin can you bring over
lori weaver
she could definitely speak to that
is she out there or is she just oh wow
must be a slow day i doubt that she's
probably doing multiple things at once
if i had to guess
your box of rocks
lori are you there
she should be there now
she's a panelist i'll put it that way
okay it's very possible that she stepped
away from her desk and
and kept us up while she was doing
something else so
um maybe we can come back to her when
she becomes available
okay yeah um so another accomplishment
is we
have increased access to nutritious food
by the snap pandemic ebt
and that was in collaboration with
department of education
and we're actually at the point of
getting ready to submit another pandemic
ebt
plan to food and nutrition services
we actually began participating in the
online purchasing program in july
which was a response to the cobin 19
pandemic when people didn't want to go
out
to stores but i definitely think this is
something we're going to continue
because there's a lot of people who
receive snap benefits who
may not have transportation maybe
elderly
maybe have young children so that's
definitely been a positive
benefit that we want to continue
we've actually another accomplishment is
i mentioned i think earlier we
have assisted people in our
new hampshire employment program
received their high school diploma or
equivalency this year
um so that was a real big benefit 128
people
and finally we continue to enhance our
collaboration with other statewide work
programs and so
really working on what are the other
programs that people can access
so that we can ensure people have access
to jobs
can i go to the next slide yes
yes you may okay thank you um some of
our key challenges
are just the continued need for
technology
to support the work of our employees and
enhance our customer service
i think that's really where we need to
continue to spend time and energy on
that
staff vacancies and turnover are
larger in this area of our division and
i will get you those vacancy
numbers but because these are
entry-level positions so
lots of people will come in um and you
know use this as a stepping stone which
is great for other
parts of the department but it kind of
causes some vacancies in this area
a challenge is always to focus on staff
training i think we really need to focus
on enhancing our training
and how it's being provided again one of
the things we learned about with covid
is um you know how to do things on zoom
right i don't think many of you thought
two years ago we'd be doing division
three
um finance on zoom um and so
how do we and how do we continue some of
that training
for our staff so that people don't have
to drive
to get access to training and then
finally
we talked about this earlier with our
division
overview is the cliff effect i mean that
is a challenge
is how do we what policies do we
look to change so that people
are encouraged to work be successful
but don't end up being worse off for
their family and essential services so
that is a challenge that we're working
through
um and i look forward to continuing our
work in this because that will be
critical
any adults any questions
great so now i'm going to go to your
favorite slide
um so we actually have
some benchmarks so for our food stamp
um there's actually national standards
that say you have to be
at six percent is the um
lowest you can that's like where you
have to be below that
for errors and so we are currently at
4.92 percent
so that is really a good we are actually
ranked fifth in the nation
um for our payment um accuracy
can i just point out on this slide that
the first two
circles there yeah what what's listed in
workload feels more like
a quality standard if you look at the
third one
you have you have a workload standard in
the third one but not the first two
okay but no this is like
it's great yeah and i mean i think part
of that is tied to our workload and so i
can actually get what our case loads are
but that helps us remain um in that
quality standard and the same with
application processing
um you know technical we are supposed to
have 90
of our applications received have to be
processed
within 30 to 45 days we're currently at
92 percent
and much of that is it is beyond our
control but yet we still have to be
tracked if somebody cancels an
appointment
if somebody doesn't show up their
application doesn't get put in a
different
um pile um and so that's something that
we have to continue to work at
and then our that's a quality standard
but i can get you the actual workload um
numbers we have here and by workload
just in case it's not clear i mean you
know what are the drivers of your
of your ftes
yeah it's the application processing so
i can tie that to that definitely
and then you'll see for our employment
supports um
we have about 50 to 60 participants for
caseloads
and that one of the standards is that we
have 50 percent of our
participants have to attend to their
required hours weekly
so in order to participate in tanf and
new hampshire employment supports you
actually have to be working
or engaged in training for um
20 to 30 hours a week
okay whoops i am
good no questions okay here is our
budgets um that we're going to review
in our when we go through the budget
slides and so you'll see the majority of
our funds
are federal and general funds
and rebecca correct me if i'm wrong some
of the other funds
used go towards our moes for medicaid
and tanf
the other fund yes is that now
sorry
the other funds or the other funds
what are those um those
are
sorry i have that
uh it's in the um
tanf budget okay
it comes from
i know there are other funds that we
collect okay
and use i can uh look into that a little
bit more
okay we'll get you that information so
we can
use this slide to look at the right to
bubbles and the total funds
look to be about the same
but the percentage of state funds to
federal funds shifts dramatically
so so what's what's the underlying story
on a huge drop in federal funds and a
huge increase
in general funds
do you follow my question yeah i see it
i'm i'm channeling rebecca on this one
in um go ahead no please go ahead
rebecca
there's um it looks like we used
less in
20 than we had
probably due to the covid because we
were using more federal dollars
than the general fund it actually looks
like rebecca that the general funds in
2021 might
be only one year where the 22 23 is two
years
just like taking a quick look okay i
think i think the middle chart is
incorrect and should actually be about
double
that mr chair and the reason that that
would be
such an increase from 1819 to 2021
those that were on the committee last
year remember
that um and i've talked about it a
little bit when we did the department
wide
presentation that we budgeted in such a
way that now we can actually tell you
where every tanf budget
dollar is budgeted well the secondary
piece to that
is we now know where every dollar of moe
is budgeted which is about 30 to 34
million i always forget the exact number
and mary usually
sends me a text and tells me i said the
wrong number so i know it's in the
you know low 30s um and so
because of that new way we budgeted um
and this is where i usually check the
attendees although it's recorded so it
doesn't matter
it's when we realized that we may not be
budgeting all of the moe
that we should have been and that we
might have a federal audit problem
because we were not
budgeting all the moe they are recorded
yeah i know i know and it's okay i think
we're past those audit ears for 18 19
i think we're okay because 2021 we
actually budgeted those dollars
um and actually made sure to spend those
general funds
to meet that moe and so that was the um
the increase that happened from 1819 to
2021 and like i said that 46 million
should actually probably be about double
that
yeah like that was just missing part of
the general funds
but we'll yeah okay so
then let's let's look at the left and
the right bubble
uh in the federal funds uh we went from
118 to 108
so we're we are we are letting air out
of that bubble
so so what's going on there is a federal
government cutting back their percentage
or is that another
kind of accounting thing no that would
be because we're
we're budgeting the um the tanf based on
or i think we'll see it when we get into
the accounting units but my my
assumption is because we are budgeting
the tanf based on current caseloads
um which as uh the director mentioned
have
been lower this year than um have been
budgeted in the past so that would
the amount of general funds we have to
spend does not change
that low 30 million dollar number we
have to spend that whether we spend one
dollar in tanf or spend
60 million in tanf um so
those those general funds will always be
budgeted
and then the amount of federal will
become the becomes the variable amount
depending on caseloads
you can keep keep going okay thank you
um so again here's our five percent
up and down um with additionals we would
actually
increase the number of field staff
so that we can have
you know work meet some of our timelines
and workload balances
we would increase our training unit
staff and dollars in staff development
we would enhance the customer service
platform so more people can do
more online um
yeah okay so the training unit staff
i i i thought and this is from two terms
ago i i
thought that there was a
department in the new hampshire state
government
that basically owned training that they
were
they were the training organization for
all state departments this sounds like
you're talking about
growing your training unit organically
within your
division so we so we actually within the
bureau of family assistance
and this training is specific to
the eligibility programs that we have
so this is on eligibility program so
this is
within our bureau of family assistance
and it's focused on
it's on you know we have staff
need to know over like 40 programs so
it's how do you
figure out what somebody's eligible for
in medicaid
in snap um for child care so it's
specific
to training to do their job um
so somebody in doit or d
dot doesn't need to know correct it's
very specific
um to um how do you process a case
in for eligibility
um and so um a decrease would be
impact on state on staff positions
loss of opportunity um
for technology enhancements we would
slow
on the timeline for adapting program
services to meet
new employer needs and staff development
won't be enhanced to meet staff needs
so those are some of the um
up and down that we would have
same general comment if these could be
made measurable
i mean these are nice general terms but
okay thank you thank you thank you um
and then
here's the different accounting units um
within the budget briefing book
and the budget book which we're going to
go over
um now i believe with karen
and rebecca yes do you want to cover
your staffing slide at all
oh sure um so just here
is our staffing we have a number of
different staff within
um within bfa so
there's 14 and office is an old term
it's really more of the the policy end
of the bureau family assistance
we have 32 people working in the bureau
of employment supports as employment
counselors
we have 370 employees out in the
district offices doing field
operations that's the eligibility
workers
one person under community service block
grant
we have 22 people in new heights
and we have 16 people in our disability
determination unit
um so that
is our staffing so it's a pretty big
bureau
so i'm going to stop my screen sharing
and i think and enable karen
to do hers
great thank you chris thank you
representative wallner has a question
before
um so chris it was just on your um
slide with all the employees i think we
saw that we talked about that before but
so most of those employees
actually were not were considered to be
front line
uh workers so that you did not have to
have the hiring freeze with most of them
right
right so for the employment support
those 32
those were direct service the 370 were
direct service
so the rest of the and the 16 for the
disability determination unit those were
all direct service i have one
i have one further question for her
that's all right
of the 370 and the 16
the direct service ones what you have
were you able to figure out what the
vacancy rate is or how many
yeah i didn't i will go back and get
that for you
right after um if that's okay um
i will provide that to the committee and
i just one more about that
so worker caseload
how many cases is a worker is one of
your eligibility
workers carrying and is it within sort
of a national
standard so the hard thing
is um is
i'm i have the i don't have the caseload
handy and so i will provide that with
you
following um but the hard thing is
because i've looked at this
representative wallner
a hundred times um from front to back
and because we do integrated eligibility
it's very hard to find a national
standard
because most states
do not have eligibility as integrated as
we do
and um so for instance when we were
working with the consultants you know
they paired us with a couple other
states and
they did everything except for you know
snap and tanf were done differently so
it's very
hard um to compare us to um
other states but i will get you that
information great
thank you chris yep so the overall
vacancy rate for this
euro is 12 percent okay
and again again when you say you're
going to get representative walnut
information you're saying you're going
to get it to mr ripple and he's going to
make sure the committee gets it
yes i will thank you even if it was for
one representative i always provide it
to kevin so he
generally distributes it to the whole
committee anyway
with that statement again
okay okay so we
are starting at
accounting unit 6125
which is located on page 973
and here is accounting unit 6125
so the director's office looks like it's
going up 4.9
and it's adding two unclassified
positions
is that is that right yes those were
previously budgeted in a different
accounting unit so they're being moved
they came from 79 96
which is in their same budget overall
it's just a different accounting unit
and i did provide kevin um the list of
all of the positions that have been
moved in the department
so those two coming over to is that
really the baseline for why
anything else might be shifting like
benefits
yes all right
i don't see any questions here okay
the next one is uh 6127 which is
employment supports
so this was the one that's the big drop
in federal money and a big
jump in state money
you know maybe the overall budget is
reduced though so that would
so here the the 9.75 is what was
budgeted
and it's being reduced to 6.1 so this
goes back to what chris was talking
about earlier about
ensuring that we're using the funds for
their most core purposes
if i might add on the other funds in
this accounting unit
for fiscal year 21 that was for
um with a granite workforce
and we that didn't pass so we did re
reduce the budget yes the work program
for granite workforce was in this
accounting unit yes
so you're saying in 21 it went from 1.3
million
to to just 11 000.
correct
where's the 11 000 coming from if
granite workforce wasn't passed
wouldn't that be zero
what line you all looking at rebecca's
looking it up right now
uh yes representative fonti ask your
question in parallel
okay part of it relates to what you okay
um
expense uh number 049 this one cares
what that is the transfer to other state
agencies
karen isn't that new hampshire
employment security
i was thinking that's what it is but uh
we need rebecca to confirm
to confirm that but i believe that's
what it is that's fine
and what language yes what what expense
line
what number here on that
049 transfer to other state agencies it
look that looks like it's going up
about 13 between the budgets on an
annual basis
that's a pretty big jump what what's
what's changing
i'll get that information for you i
don't know it off the top of my head
but where were you looking with the with
the 1.3 million to 11 000. what line was
that on jess
oh what started this was uh
my looking at just the general funds
versus the federal funds
from budget to budget where
uh in the in the in the current budget
state funds is about 29 of the total
in in in next budget it's going to be 43
percent
you're my total funds but there was a
you threw around numbers 1.3 million to
11 000. where was that
oh um that was in here
975. that's your transfers
that's the that's here it's the yeah if
you look here on the screen where it
shows the different types of revenues
the 1.3 was here in fiscal year 21
and is now 11 000. okay
so we'll follow up with both of those
questions what this 11 000 is
as well as the uh transfers to other
state agencies and why that's increasing
thanks and i'm sorry which line is it
that you were talking about the
other state agencies the transfer to
other state agencies do you happen to
know where that's going and why it
increased
double or i think the question
ms rounds is is more like if the granite
workforce
prop program went away then what is this
000. if there's no program there it
should be zero
yes that's one question i thought the
second question was
why did the transfer to other state
agencies go up correct
yes yes online their
expenses 49. okay 45.
so we we can we can get those later
okay we will get both of those answers
for you
so those are our payments that are paid
to new hampshire employment securities
we get the budget from them
they provide us with the numbers so we
align our budget with theirs
what are they providing for services
chris
oh it's online access cross match
yeah there's a bunch of things that we
have a number of
mlus i can get a summary of that um so i
don't
um misspeak it's related to working and
accessing benefits and all of that stuff
and unemployment
so i'm sure this isn't happening but
i could imagine a really creative
accounting
where one department in division one
charges a department in division three
much more money so that there's more
money in the state
system as a result of it because i don't
have time to go coordinate with division
one to find out what's going on
so absolutely i can assure you that i
would not pay an agency more than
they need to provide the services to us
i i would throw a stink about that
because that
affects my budget and affects my ability
to
operate the entire budget so i would
absolutely not allow that to happen
i believe that thank you for that and
i'm sorry i exposed one of my cynical
sides to you
it's okay we all have fun about
different things so totally
understandable
all right do you want to continue on the
next budget area
sure so the next accounting unit is 6146
which is tanf the temporary assistance
needy families
what i would mention is we did have a
prioritized need
for fiscal year 22 only for
six hundred thousand dollars were about
six hundred thousand dollars under
the required moe um so you will see that
on
the spreadsheet of all of the
prioritized means which
i should have to early next week okay i
i appreciate you saying that um while
i'm making notes in the excel sheet
could you tell me
what funding line or what expense line
you're gonna want the money in so i
believe that would go in class line 501
correct payments to clients yes
so the note there is you think this is
600 000 low
yes well the general fund piece is
so um it would reduce the federal funds
by 600 000 and increase the general
funds
oh so the the actual expenditure would
not change
that just the fund mix would change down
here
why can't we do it the other way and get
more federal money
we we definitely draw down every other
federal dollar we can
um but we do have to spend the entire
moe
mj has a question don't tell me moe
again what's that miranda
okay maintenance of effort all right so
um representative uh walner has her hand
up
yeah karen
yes so can you talk for a minute i i
don't know maybe
maybe you have already gone over this
with the division but can you
talk a little bit about maintenance of
effort and what it means
i mean what do we put at risk if we
don't meet our maintenance with effort
sure so um it's a common
misunderstanding that
match and moe are the same thing they
are slightly different
and uh it's something that i quite
frankly didn't understand when i first
started with the department either and
and mary had to spend a lot of time with
me saying you cannot use those words
interchangeably they're two very
different things
um so match is uh a percentage
that if you spend a federal federal
dollar
you have to spend a general fund dollar
sometimes it's 50 50. so it's a dollar
to a dollar
sometimes it's 25.75 or 90 10.
or lots of other various percentages um
so that is a match and moe is that you
have to spend that much in general funds
regardless of how many federal dollars
you spend
so there is a slight difference there
there can also be changes to the moe for
example
under the cares act
to receive the enhanced fmap and
medicaid
part of the required maintenance of
effort
is to not take anyone off of medicaid
so that's not really a
general fund that must be spent kind of
moe
it's actually an activity that we have
to do
for moe and as we get down into some of
the other programs
like um uh
apt that's similar it's not that the
federal government says you have to
spend
you know 10 million dollars on aptb they
say
you have to have this program and so
whatever it costs to run that program is
what it costs to run the program so
so that's where moe and match are a
little bit different
a really great explanation so it's like
moe is the fixed
cost where you've got you got to get
into the program
and then the match is really sort of
like the variable cost to get
additional federal money yes the the
match is directly tied to
how many federal dollars you spend
but the moe can vary
based on whether it's an moe to run a
program or an moe of a fixed amount of
dollars you must spend
sometimes we get a good deal out of it i
remember in division two
school lunches when we first started
with school lunches it was like a
one-on-one match
and then it became a maintenance of
effort
and by the time 20 years went by
the uh maintenance effort was
exactly the same but the federal funds
were about 10 times more
so sometimes the maintenance of effort
is you know just you got to make some
little effort but they're
giving you more money every year but the
maintenance of effort sometimes it's a
historical thing
it doesn't change every year whereas
match likely does
yes
i wish i had more programs that that
happened where the moe stayed the same
for lots and lots and lots of years uh
that is true of tanf that
has been the same oe for many many years
but um
that is also a very high moe so so
representative
your hands up is that a follow-up or
just an artifact
a far it's a follow-up actually karen
i would we've had like i was just going
to say that we have had this maintenance
of effort
um for a number of years and it was a
formula set
many many years ago um
do you have what do you remember what
that
what that what what that formula was
um i did not i was just looking to see
if man
mary is still a panelist it looks like
she's not in her other meeting anymore
i bet mary remembers yeah because i
think
i think it's from when we when tana
started it's with the same formula and
the same
moe um and we didn't have
one penalty though in like
i'm not gonna get the year right it was
the 80s or 90s there was a small penalty
that ended up increasing our moe
i don't see that mary's typing to me so
she if i could i don't know the formula
but i think the moe and the federal
grant were both put in place in the 1996
federal uh welfare reform bill and it'd
been the same ever since
okay yeah
and i i would i would add there's been
at
many times where uh reform has been
added to current bills
at the federal level and so far no
changes have been made to it but it's
something
i know chris monitors i monitor mary
monitors because um
changes the program would affect us yeah
there's um
we keep on preparing for tana freoth and
it keeps on getting extended and
extended
um so
thank you
all right okay
i'm gonna come down to uh 6153
which is on the bottom of page 976 and
the beginning
of 977 as chris mentioned earlier in her
presentation
this accounting unit is moe to tanf so
any
reduction here in general funds would
mean we would just have to
increase general funds somewhere else to
continue to meet the moe
the same is also true uh chris of 6170
is that tanf
moa um that that's medicaid moe
if that's old age assistance
okay not hearing any questions so i'm
just going to continue down to 61.71
it's the needy and fine france
is that also sometimes moe
yes yes
all of the general funds in these
programs here
are related to moe right karen
yes either medical medicaid or tanf yep
yes
i'm learning
the next one 6172 uh does refer back to
a question that came up earlier
about um budgeting for the refugee
grants here
we've budgeted based on what we've
experienced in 2020
not any potential anticipated increase
is that that must feel like the right
way to go for you
i i i i understand that the
new administration anticipates opening
up the refugee
pipeline a little bit more and it does
look like the source of funds is a
transfer from another agency so i'm not
sure
if um there would potentially be
additional funds that could be
transferred for
if this ends up higher
in the first year or two the feds send a
hundred percent
of what the our refugee cost is supposed
to be
is that is that true i don't know the
answer to that question
and i believe this area is specific for
the benefits that are under
um bureau family assistance but we can
get all that information for you
um in a follow up for the committee
so my main thought on that is just uh to
double check your budgeting assumption
about changes in refugee volumes
and i don't think i need any information
back i just would like you to just
double check that
you're you you think you're budgeting
properly and if
and if you got a different number for us
after thinking it through again you know
just come back
all right we will do that and um to
the earlier question about how does this
budget relate to
uh the office of health equity that you
heard about earlier these
are actually transferred from the office
of health equity so these are
transferred within the department
which line was that oh
[Music]
it's it's within the ocon budget
i don't remember the accounting units
off the top of my head you know that
we're looking at right now one is the
6172 double od that's what you're
talking about
yes yeah these are coming over from an
ocom budget
so we will take a look at that and we'll
submit a change request if if we think
um there's any need to
okay um and then we come down to
aptd grants um you will notice that
fiscal year 20 here
is higher than fiscal year 21.
this budget the aptd budget was reduced
in the house phase
from the agency and governor budgets
for 20 and 21 they were reduced based on
caseload assumptions that the house had
done and they were
the case loads we experienced did not
drop as much as
um the house had anticipated so we
are budgeting those where we believe
those case loads will be
this uh we did have to do transfers of
general funds
into this uh class line and i anticipate
we will have to do the same in fiscal
year 21 probably about a million dollars
a million and a half dollars
so we are budgeting uh a slate reduction
from 20 um in
22 and 23. again these are areas as
chris spoke to
that as the unemployment benefits change
if the economy
continues to be down
that we will start to see increases in
these in this budget
and i'm getting a message from rebecca
that we already moved 1.3 million in
fiscal year 21 at the last
or in one of the past few fiscal
meetings probably in the department-wide
transfer
all right uh
6176 is state assistance montana
hold on just one second yeah so that
line you're just talking about
karen that's also moe money is that
correct yes this is moe to medicaid
so you have to spend it you have correct
we have to operate this program under
medicaid so
if it's under budgeted we have to
transfer funds we cannot say
oh we're shutting off the program we're
out of money we have to operate at
to receive the match in medicaid this is
direct cash assistance to individuals
that have disabilities
so
6176 which is at the top of page 980
you have a question keith you look like
you raise your hand a moment
sorry i had my mute on yeah i don't have
a question
the next one is uh 7148 which is
a community services block brand we call
that csvg for short
did we go over that in the slide deck
what what is that yep
that is money that goes to the cap
agencies that was in the
um department over the division overview
and that's a hundred percent
pass-through money from the fed
from the federal government it's um
to go and it's in legislation it goes to
the cap
agencies to do poverty reduction
there is a small amount of general funds
there as well sorry thousand dollars
which is most likely related to the
employee
and their cost allocation
good thank you one employee
the accounting unit at the bottom of
this page is 80 25 which was workman's
workman's comp um that as i mentioned
we've moved to the ocom budget this is
one of those areas that i mentioned had
a smaller
budget and that we consolidated
departmentwide
7215 as ssbt
okay so um
i have no question
rebecca what was the change in ssbg that
uh
general funds are now required here
um
the nature of this program looks to have
shifted too right if you're going from
contracts
to grants that's actually the change
from contracts to grants was what i
spoke about earlier
that um to better track the
sub-recipient contracts we've moved
those to class 74.
so it doesn't necessarily mean that the
program's changed we're just trying to
track it better
okay so this um ssbg
came from dcyf and there was another
piece
that we used to fund the contracts
for the community our comprehensive
family
support services and the general fund
piece
came from a different accounting unit
within bfa so we just kind of put them
all in one spot
so they're not new general funds they're
just moved from no
right
i don't see any questions okay
uh 72-16 is the kinship grant
100 federal this again has that change
from 102
to 74 for us to better track
it's really about the single audit the
audit that's done by kpmg
this helps us better track for that
we did have a prioritized feed for this
one
it's not really a grant though is it i
mean technically
if you're paying a pmg
no no i'm sorry i was saying that that's
why we moved it from 102 to 74 not to
pay kpmg
to better track it for reporting
purposes when kpmg audits us
oh okay sorry about that no that's right
uh so so is is it is it technically a
grant that
instead of a contract the the actual
vehicle
the the acquisition vehicle is changing
from contract to grant
and the grants program has a better
tracking system
no so it it still would be a contract uh
but 74 class line 74
allows us to put just the contracts that
are related to sub-recipient monitoring
which are more grant-like but we still
use a contract vehicle with the
contracts unit
it means that they are providing
services on our behalf
so so you know it better than i do but
if if you look at it later and you think
there's a different word than grant
because
i think contracts and grants have
different meanings
i just i just want to keep all the
wording transparent
for the public to look at i totally
understand
this is a little bit of a round peg in a
square hole we
did request of department of
administrative services to create
a class line for us specific to track
and
they told us that we were not able to
add a class line so we had to select a
class line that was most applicable
um and then explain it so this is one of
those situations
so 74 was not a class sign that we
typically used
so this allowed us to use that for this
purpose
thank you
okay i don't see any other questions
rebecca you did mention that there is a
prioritized need here
correct 325 000
for each year how much
325 000
mary jane has her hand up chess uh
go ahead uh represent walter i was um
the chairman i was just gonna let you
know that i need to leave at exactly
three o'clock
for a phone call so i will um
we're in in bedford tomorrow i i'm
sensing we're really close to being done
so
enjoy your phone call and we'll see you
tomorrow okay
i'll wave at you in a distance okay see
you tomorrow bye bye
bye um and what what was that
prioritized
for i'm sorry it was
for the facilitating organization
yeah sure that um is it provides um
support that we talked about earlier in
the um division overview
to assist um to increase um supports to
the family resource centers
that provide primary prevention services
to families
and to really coordinate the services
that will focus on the prevention and
mitigation
of child abuse and neglect and
maltreatment and also
expand the kinship navigation program so
it can be offered statewide
with the increasing number of parents or
grandparents raising grandchildren
and family members um you know there's a
huge need for increased kinship support
so it sounds like that ought to be
coming from a domestic and sexual
violence account
um i'm not sure
um if you're talking about child abuse
wouldn't well it's to it's to provide
support services so that
you're providing parenting education
through the family resource centers
um and home visiting services so that
parents can raise
bees stronger parents and reduce child
maltreatment and the incidence of it so
they don't have to become involved
with dcyf so it's a prevention
okay but it doesn't all right so i don't
want to
take this down a tangent but it seems
like the domestic and sexual violence
accounts
also pay for prevention but not for
um for children is not my understanding
but that was under domestic that
children are
included that child abuse or abuse
between a parent and a child
is part of that i'm gonna defer to karen
and rebecca on that but that's not my
understanding and we don't
we get very in this division the only
funds we have
um to assist um individuals who have
domestic violence are for our shelter
programs
um and to support some of the shelters
for
people who are fleeing domestic violence
i don't think i have anything to add it
it may be a question that you could ask
to direct your ribsum when dcyf presents
as the domestic violence funds are
within his budget
okay
will you still be here miss rounds oh
you got me the whole time
you don't get to get rid of me okay very
good
with me um all right so we're down to
79.93 which is field eligibility and
operations
this is a relatively big budget right
yes
yes this is where those 370 staff
live so i already talked about um
trying to come up with a workload
benchmark and is this the one where you
said it's hard to do because
you guys do an integrated service
approach
but i will get you the best that we have
um
and the best comparisons
can i ask a general question
i've seen this in a number of places
under the
personal services permanent classified
second year they tend to have a i don't
know five to six percent
increase there is that just a
generalized wage increase
it would be the step increases that we
as a department we cannot edit those
numbers department of administrative
services provides the numbers so it has
to be because of step
increases okay thank you
okay
all right the next one is 7214 which is
new heights
and as you heard about yesterday the
this is really the staff for new heights
the contracts for new heights with
deloitte are within the doit
okay budget the permanent there are the
positions are down there
you only have 22 for new heights
yes
we have created another salaried
position is that what that is
it would have been moved from somewhere
else go ahead rebecca
oh the two um unclassifieds were moved
into the bfa
the 6125 budget
that we saw before
the people still be working on new
futures or or new heights rather
um yeah they're in the director's office
plus up of one fte
what was the basic justification for the
one fte increase do you know
do you know where the one classified
employee increase came from
or the one increase in employees correct
not
it was an overall it's um actually so we
have one position that is an
eight t that we're converting to a
full-time permanent position
and that's where that one comes from
for what reason
it's all right keep going
rebecca i do have a question about that
later we can connect
um 7997 is i believe the last one
in this bureau which is the disability
determination unit on page 987
so this looks like a pretty big jump in
federal funds
if we if we eliminate what looks to be a
covet jump
in 21
[Music]
it is a reduction from the from the
21 budget though
i think it's more just bringing the
budget in line with actuals
so the budget fiscal year 21 adjusted
authorized was 2.8 million
and we have it down to 2.3 which is more
in line with where the actuals were in
fiscal year 20.
it looks like the consultant budget is
um
significantly less yeah we actually
moved we had
a contract with umass and then we had
independent
um medical consultant contracts and we
collapsed it all into the one contract
very good thank you no questions
okay then i think that concludes it does
the accounting units for
the fa yep 7997
hey it's a great job thank you thank you
so much
chris i hope you recover
it was a long day i hope you guys
recover from me as well so
thank you for your questions your
interest um
and we will get back to you once we hear
back from kevin
okay so before we say goodbye does
anyone
have anything for the good of the
committee that they want to say
about now i i have just one uh first
thank you chris rebecca
mary all the bureau chiefs that were on
in the background i appreciate it
i also wondered if you would discuss
when tuesday might be moved to today so
that i can let the directors know
um scheduling is always difficult with
directors so i just want to make sure
talking about march 2nd right
yes as much notice as possible yeah i
so i don't know if mr ripples had a
chance to think through it but i haven't
had a chance to talk to him yet i just
know we need to get it off with a second
i was wondering if the committee members
uh would consider next friday a
reasonable substitute friday the 5th
i'm reluctant to reschedule it to a day
when you already have other things
scheduled
because they have been no it should be
its own day
dcyf's a big one so um
i i i i'm not looking at a calendar
so you think march 5th is a
it seems like we have a lot of joint
fiscal committees on fridays
is that a is that a conflict that you
know there's not a fiscal committee
on the ship now okay
um so uh representative norgren it
looked like you wanted to say something
no i think that looks clear for other
house businesses
so that would be fine okay
and then representative rogers did you
have a comment
i know representative weiler does
representative weiler did you want to
say something sir
we have anything scheduled for friday
26th or monday
you don't have anything scheduled for
this friday although i think hhs has
some prior commitments that
they have to be i like county meeting on
friday
and i'll give a meeting friday as well
on this coming monday you do actually
have a division three meeting
already scheduled
yeah we're trying to get off of tuesday
right
so that's like substituting substituting
friday for tuesday might
might be the best idea yeah
you have a problem with that sir that
seems to be a consensus building
john the fifth yes yeah sure yeah that's
good
and i think karen did you karen did you
want to start at 10 30 instead of 9 30.
i would request that i do i'm the uh
department's um designee to the
opioid abatement advisory commission um
that senator rosenwald set up for that
friday
um that starts at nine o'clock so i i
think that i could leave that meeting by
10 30
um and be able to to be over with with
you all if that works
i would be very appreciative okay so
just
just to confirm we're only doing dcyf
on on the fifth
because there were there was like a a
two-parter on the
on tuesday wasn't there we were going to
finish this one off and then hit dcyf
we did have uh the division of
behavioral health as a two-parter on
monday and tuesday
so the plan was to start off on monday
with new hampshire hospital and
glencliff
and also the division of behavioral
health karen do you think we could get
through
all of those in one day i think the
potential exists we probably
um i i would say that to get through
both of those and one day we probably
would need to work past
four o'clock would be my guess but we
probably could
get them done in one day can we do any
of them friday morning
just to put a big dent in it or to
separate them like
i've never gone over the new hampshire
hospital or glencliff
is that are those
really long not typically new hampshire
hospital and glencliff both have quite a
few accounting units
but the purpose is all the same right
it's all operating the facility so there
the questions are typically less on
those accounting units
um but i think that if we started at 10
30 on friday
if we need to wrap up anything
behavioral health it probably wouldn't
take more than an hour
and then we would have the rest of the
day for dcyf
just to give you a heads up jess on
monday afternoon i won't be there for a
few hours at a doctor's appointment
you also have talking about i'm going
for 38.
pardon me which monday are we talking
about
first off monday the we're talking about
monday the
first because we're trying to uh
uh eliminate the second and the second
had a couple of things going on all
right
a little late to the uh the first
will be you'll be late on the first
that was a question i don't know i um
that for me
yes so let's let's take this offline i
think we're
we have a 90 solution so if if
kevin and karen if you would stick
around
let's let's let's lock this down and
we'll get word out to everyone on what
we're going to do
right so so for everyone else thank you
so much
we are adjourned and you can now have
your corona rebecca
i'm corona on the beach
okay so so i i'm i was getting a little
confused there
um and because i still don't have a
calendar up in front of me
but the goal is to take march 2nd
it had two things going on dcyf was the
big thing we're going to move that to
the fifth right
yes let me just
there are a couple attendees here let me
just remove them
yeah we should be out of public at this
point
yeah and i don't think i can i can stop
the recording but i don't think